hey there folks welcome to sector G our
live broadcasting venue here at PAX
Prime I'm your host Chris Waters let me
hear from the audience who's here eating
a bunch of bacon and ready to watch a
live
show that was way Lou I'm impressed that
was way louder than I expected you guys
are great uh joining me on the couch
here we got Justin hawald and Peter
Brown hi guys
bu big fans of bacon yeah I'm more of a
sausage man you're more of a sausage man
definitely more of a sausage man we can
tell that by looking ater
uh so we're going to kick off the show
today uh PX Prime usually not a place
where like a whole ton of news comes out
but lone behold on Friday Nintendo was
it a Nintendo Direct they always do the
Nintendo Direct stuff it was a Nintendo
Direct it's not related to packs at all
this all this came out before packs
really and this is a Japan only event
where they announced a new 3DS a new 3DS
and it's literally called new 3DS no
it's not it is that's it there's no
letters after it or there are so you can
get a standard new 3DS or the new 3DS
over there the XL is called the LL and
so that you can get the new 3DS LL and
it has some extra buttons extra buttons
yeah two extra shoulder buttons going to
be on this thing it's uh has an extra
analog nub oh okay and you say nub does
that mean it's different from the sort
of pad it's like yeah it literally is
like a little rubber nub that's probably
going to fit in the Center of your thumb
and that's about it you're used to that
be in like laptops yeah like oneye old
laptop and it you know it's something
that's made for the the Dual stick game
games that need that that dual analog
control and one of them is Xenoblade
yeah that the Wii U game from monolith
oh yeah it's going to get ported and
it's only going to work on the new 3DS
and for Japan they're going to get that
really soon it's coming out in October
America and the UK maybe in 2015 maybe
sometime in the future well I they're
probably going to see how well it does
over there just you see what kind of
reception something like that gets uh
but it it does have a faster processor
it's supposed to have better 3D from
what we've been told where you know when
you're holding your 3DS now you have to
like get that perfect angle and then if
you move your head slightly you just get
a massive headache this one's supposed
to just get that 3d effect no matter how
you're holding it oh really a little bit
more flexibility but uh Xenoblade that
was a huge RPG for me and people love
that one it was definitely beloved in
the gam spot office uh you think it I
mean that that seems like a great to
have on a portable handheld I mean it's
you know Monster Hunter has thrived on
handhelds as well I I prefer those
longer experiences on a handheld
something that you can take with you
that you don't have to worry about
sitting in front of your TV for hours
and hours well the game is designed for
it too it has so many side quests I want
to say like a few hundred and uh all of
those will last you just about a few
minutes right so you could just imagine
play one of those on the go you're done
come back later close the shell you're
good Y and one of the other reasons that
they're going through this redesign is
because you have those amiibo figures
that are coming out really soon and this
one's going to have a built-in NFC
Reader so right now for the regular 3DS
there's going to be an adapter that
you'll be able to get in the US and if
you get one of the amiibos for I I think
it only works for Smash Brothers so far
you get the adapter and you'll be able
to use it but in Japan you'll have a
system that you just place it onto and
it'll work right away have the amiibos
started rolling out yet when do they
release cuz we've been hearing about
them for a while the release date right
now is like tentative on Amazon it's
December 31st 2014 so basically no one
knows yet yeah it's going to this year
no no I think oh really yeah we're just
not a positive win all right I are you
guys so amiibos are the little figurines
but they didn't talk too much about
amiibos at the NFC event but they did
talk about a couple other games right
well so we have some games on the show
floor just like any other uh any of
these other shows we have a lot of e3
stuff a lot of Gamescom stuff and if
you're on the show floor everyone is
playing Smash Brothers that is you know
one of the most exciting games to play
but there's some other things to check
out and and one of those is uh Hyrule
Warriors High rule Warriors yeah they
have a bunch of kiosks of to play there
has anybody here played Hyrule Warriors
yet that guy all right two guys what
about Smash Brothers for the Wii U you
guys tried that out more people a little
bit more popular so to be completely
honest I I hate Warriors games when I
was I used to be a reviews editor and
the Warriors games were the things that
we gave people as punishment really you
were like vindictively like listen man
your last assignment was late like you
messed up you know what's going to
happen it's in your code of conduct you
you have to review the next Warriors
game it's Warriors but I'm actually a
little bit more sold on this because it
does have that that whole Zelda trapping
and the thing that we got to do in this
time as you can see on the screen is we
got to play around with Ganon and this
was a free play mode it's not
necessarily a part of the story like
this because you might see link running
around with you in in some of these
other sections but you'll be able to go
back to stages that you already beat and
once you unlock some of these characters
and one of them being Ganon you can play
through the the game with him and take
on a giant purple plant that barfs
plants and is called man handia I don't
manhandle manhandler hey anyways uh so
you got a chance to play it Peter yeah
well I've played in the past I didn't
play it at this show but um I mean look
it really is a Warriors game through and
through it has a lot of the Zelda you
know like touches like the music like
these little things that remind you of
Zelda yeah so that kind of is like a
nice little thing that like draws out a
pavlovian response but you know I mean
you kind of have to have an affinity for
this sort of game um this sort of game
being like I'm a power hero Pitt it
against endless hordes of enemies I can
just shred through them pretty easily
most part nice way saying button Masher
yeah sure you know I like to use more
words when less we'll do fine it's an
interesting experiment though because
Nintendo is not usually one to sort of
lend out its properties it's tried it in
the past but uh working with KO is
definitely unusual but those games are
really really popular in Japan MH it's
something we're probably going to see a
a lot more of these Brands going out to
maybe be worked on by some other
developers yeah well we certainly saw it
last week with the announcement of
pocken poken tournament which is Tekken
plus Pokemon so poken yeah IE no com but
to be clear there are no Tekken
characters it's not going to play
exactly like Tekken but it's made by the
same team run by the same director
katsuhira Hara and uh it's hitting
Japanese arcades first which is a really
interesting thing Nintendo rarely
dabbles in arcades these days I think
maybe once in a while there's a Mario
Kart or an f-zero game but it's super
rare so so and that's you play as the
Pokémon in a fighting game but that was
no one's gotten their hands on that yet
they just announced it Rec it's only
announced and we're assuming it's
probably only going to be fighting type
Pokemon you're not necessarily going to
be able to be Pikachu they said that's
not true oh is it not true do you get to
be Pikachu good job newsman like a big
musle Pikachu yeah no honestly it's not
just the fighting type Pokemon that's
what they showed off probably just to
give people a real sense for you know
what the action is going to be like but
they were on records saying that no
we're going to be expanding just beyond
those types I mean I can't imagine you
would launch a Pokemon fighting game and
there would be no Pikachu yeah I think
it'll be like four Pikachu standing on
top of one
another coat yeah the megachu that's
what it's called
totally all right so this is hyru
warriors uh that's playable is that is
this coming out this year or is this mhm
yeah slated for I think it's coming yeah
coming this fall people will be able to
to play it very soon um and this was
also put together with Team ninja as you
can see maybe by the character design
and that's not totally uh standard
Nintendo definitely we see a little team
ninja influence there maybe I think a
small amount of Team ninja it's not that
small you might you might be able to
tell what part they had a had a hand in
influencing there not the small parts uh
so that but they're uh you know team
ninja is sort of a combat Focus Studio
they they're they're fighting I guess
their you know would be their
contribution they're definitely known
for fighting and for things like dead or
alive yep yes they are uh so hro
Warriors is out on the pack show floor
folks can play it here uh what else
what's another sort of game they've they
got out there there there's one called
Fantasy Life Fantasy Life yeah this is
like this a game from level five I
believe level being developed well it's
being published by level five and
Nintendo and developed with by brownie
Brown they're one of the guys who did
the uh Lon section uh the RPG section of
one of the lon games uh they also helped
develop Mother 3 yeah they made a a Mana
game on Game Boy Advance when that first
came out so they they have a really good
pedigree of making these fun RPGs and
and when you're playing it there's a a
game that came out recently I don't
think it really resonates with our
readers Disney Magical life though
Disney life that sounds wonderful who
doesn't want to live the Disney Magical
life this is like that but uh with a
more standard fantasy type trappings
where you can take on different classes
and be you know a warrior or a paladin
or maybe a cook or a
blacksmith uh so this in this gameplay
footage the person just changed their
life to a blacksmith yeah you're I mean
you're literally living out a fantasy
life it's that easy just like just like
in real life you decide I want to be a
paladin today guess I'll be Paladin and
and it kind of borrows some stuff from
Final Fantasy 11 where you can take on
these classes and level up in them and
then when you want to change over to
something else you still have some of
the abilities from there it's but you're
not going to lose all of the progress
that you already made so you can you'll
start from level one as a cook but you
still have all the stuff that you did as
a paladin you're not going to and then
if you choose to be a blacksmith you're
not going to forget how to make lasagna
yeah right uh so is it I mean is it like
uh animal crossing esque at all in terms
of the sort of
daytoday just doing tasks around around
town kind of thing or there Adventures
to go on if you're an adventurer it I I
guess you could call it like an animal
crossing RPG because there are there is
a combat element there are things to do
outside of just the Animal Crossing
being a more of a life
experience this is more of a game there
is a Cooking Mama type aspect where if
you're the if you're the blacksmith and
you're going to make your sword you do
have to do some timing type events to to
get it just right and if you do it
really well it'll have like a a little
star thing that came up they like oh you
made a really good Ladle delightful and
then you decorate your home Peter I know
you're huge on interior design oh don't
get me
started uh so this one another 3DS game
uh was it is that slated for release
this year is that recently announced no
it's not recently announced this has
actually been out in Japan for the last
year I'm really up on my Japanese game
releases as you can tell but it it's
something that I think will resonate
we'll find an audience here in the
states it's coming out in October I'm
personally excited like as someone who
put hundreds of hours into Animal
Crossing which I probably shouldn't
admit out loud I I'm very very excited
to to play this but probably not a game
for everyone I mean you you can look at
it and see like oh it's kind of cartoony
if you're into that kind of collecting
and and maybe playing with friends and
and trading stuff if you fun things
maybe you'll like fun I mean there is
the whole not a game for everyone that's
I mean there's no game that's for
everyone well when I say that I except
for Tetris if you don't like Tetris go
home and there's a distinct lack of
decapitations there's probably very
little blood coming out when you slice
through people you're not allowed to
slice through people no I mean it
doesn't seem like a real slice through
people kind of game what we you see some
mining going on yeah to explore caves
and
Forest lots of enemies and and things
like that to fight it's a it's a weird
it's an interesting mix of genres that I
think it'll be a lot of fun neat uh all
right so some Nintendo games on display
here new 3DS coming down the pipe uh
what do you guys think of sort of
Nintendo what's what are you looking
forward to in the Nintendo verse over
the coming months like and you you down
with some Bayonetta 2o are you looking
forward to getting your smash on
anything personally exciting for you
guys well smash is is of course the
dominant game when you come to something
like pack even at E3 like just seeing
the the level excite of excitement the
number of people just gathered around
these stations three it's going to come
out on 3DS first which is not you know
it's not the best version of the game
like we we're definitely be holding out
we're still waiting for that Wii U
version but 3DS is still a lot of fun I
mean you know you get around like we get
around and play Mario Kart you get
around and play
Smash but I feel like you know the the
screen size challenge you probably want
an LL for that one or XL yeah yeah XL is
is going to help a lot and it's just
such a wide array of Fighters I know
some of them have been leaked we're not
totally sure how how much we can trust
those uh those reports that have come
out but they look really realistic and
one of those that that came out was the
Duck Hunt dog the Duck Hunt dog and I
don't know if this is true or not but I
am I'm really excited to to play as the
Duck Hunt dog if this is real because I
heard someone saying like he's a dog
that you run around you can throw ducks
at people and I imagine his final smash
is going to be like having the reticule
on screen and being able to shoot at
people and then at the end he just comes
up and
goes such a ridiculous thing like
smashes everyone as a like Smash
Brothers is a ridiculous game and like
that just cements it gloriously
ridiculous what about you or anything on
your radar you know what man I just want
more Virtual Console games Nintendo did
such a good job on the Wii and like
they're kind of getting better at doing
it with the 3DS now the Wii U is still
flagging I just want the entire Library
back I know there's a lot of Licensing
issues um but yeah I'm a big fan of
Nintendo's Legacy stuff and the games
that were built for their system so
personally speaking their big stuff is
okay I'm not the biggest smash fan but I
think man if they spent more time on
their Virtual Console maybe they
wouldn't be in so much trouble
financially I I'm just saying you hey
you know people love that the old
Nintendo stuff you know bring it out on
shot it out on the Virtual Console well
and they have the second screen
experience with the Wii U controller
it's perfect for that like it's a it's a
massive screen you can play these old
games on you take what they need to do
they need to integrate these systems
together so that if you buy a game on
the 3DS it's going to carry over to the
Wii uu you don't have to buy like three
copies of Mega Man you know what they
might do and I'm saying this only
because it has all the extra buttons and
the analog stick they might phase out
the gam pad from the Wii U and make the
new XL an optional gam pad an optional
game pad for the wi I like the way you
think it's got a stronger CPU it's got
more buttons what more do you need you
just need more buttons no but seriously
and it's got like a it's got like a
really nice dock that they were a they
were showing as well um if they do that
I'll be really excited about that cuz I
want a Wii U but I kind of don't like
the gam pad and its current iteration y
so it was really funny when they
announced it Peter I I showed Peter as
well and he was like oh that looks
really cool and then they showed the doc
he was like oh my god did you see that
dock that is so hot I'm a sucker for
docs what can I say from Nintendo for
the new 3DS uh Justin hawald Peter Brown
thank you guys so much for chatting a
little Nintendo uh I'll release you into
the packs Wilds uh to play games or
board games or try to get more pins I
know you're a pin Chaser I am I'm a that
think it sound dirty and wrong it is a
little dirty but not wrong all right uh
we're going to head over uh Mary and I
got to play Borderlands the Pre-Sequel
like two days ago and I got to play as
clap trap which is really fun cuz he's
like a sassy little robot that like
maybe doesn't seem like the coolest guy
to play ass but turns out it's kind of
cool so we're going to toss to me from
this morning when we recorded this thing
I'm wearing the same shirt but no I'll
be back live also the same Shir it's
it's not very confusing I'm making it
way more complicated than it is let's
hear from me and Mary about clap
trap people like here at P Prime it's
tiny sassy robots killing a bunch of
stuff hi I'm Chris Waters join by Mary
Kish Mary good morning good morning uh
let's talk about clap trap Borderlands
the Pre-Sequel you and I got to play
yesterday I played as clap trap you
played as Nisha yeah dual wielding
that's right you these like ornate guns
uh we'll talk about Nisha another time
it's all about the robots assassin
people so you play as clap trap and like
they've said before your your point of
view is a little lower but here we see
this is what I want to talk about really
he is shorter he's he's now turned into
a pirate ship on this footage and this
is Vault hunter.exe his action skill and
what it does is uh selects from a random
P or a package of unlocked abilities and
so this one puts these four cannons
around the sides of the screen starts
playing the 1812 Overture that's right
and just starts shooting cannons every
it's a mix of uh something that's
actually really helpful in battle but
incredibly funny and enjoyable because
the explosions do go off to the beat so
it's
like and you get this like awesome
awesome feedback from the Cannons that
are attached to all corners of your tiny
body it's delightful and apparently he
like also looks like a tiny pirate ship
when that happens obviously you can't
see it in the first person view but
that's just one of the different things
that his action skill kind of analyzes
and chooses based on what's going on so
I think I was facing a badass enemy
there we brought out the big guns but uh
you you were around for another one it
was a grenade party yeah he's he's such
a fantastic enjoyable character because
he's always like kind of like this
slurms McKenzie like oh like let's liven
up the party and for some reason we're
all in this intense battle and it's
getting really heated and people are
starting to dial around us we need some
help and he just says grenades for
everyone and and just throws grenades
onto the ground I actually needed a
bunch we were fighting a boss it was
really helpful and I just gathered them
all up and and just started throwing
bombs out left and right another one
that maybe we'll take a look at is uh
you turned into a rubber ducky uh so
like the Cannons were intruding on The
View before a giant rubber duck head
just pops up and you're always bouncing
uh now you as Nisha like you still get
to experience the kind of like
floatiness of the Pre-Sequel because
you're on the moon there's less gravity
there's people are butt stomping
everywhere uh I love the butt stomping
it's a great additional mechanic that I
really enjoyed when in doubt butt
stomp out a really nice AOE around
giraffe and I find it really enjoyable I
had ice on mine so every time my butt
stomped everyone around me froze gave me
a lot of time to be able bble to take
them out uh you had a few different
types yeah well I did this this one
right here you see is a corrosive damage
and fart obviously it's a fart joke uh
cuz it's Borderlands uh so that one's
really amusing and then when you're the
rubber ducky you're always bouncing so
you can just butt stomp butt stomp butt
Stomp all the time like crazy uh so
playing as clap trap is it's that action
skill the Vault hunter.exe introduces
this kind of Randomness but they're all
helpful I mean another one is he just
throws down a little turret like Axton
in the original Borderlands and it just
starts shooting tons of uh missiles out
at any enemy there you saw a second win
skill that like sends out a tiny little
explosive homeing clap tra to just blow
up whoever's nearby very helpful for
getting a second wind yeah I notice that
often um you do end up depleting your
life pretty easily you can get taken out
quickly but you uh rarely need to
restart you can easily get a second wind
as clap trap kind of like just
encouraging you to go for it and another
another thing that I really love clapt
is kind of like this controversial
character sometimes these some people
love him some people hate him I love the
fact that as Nisha when I was playing
with you I was able to give you the old
melee high five that was one of my
favorite parts of you playing as clap
trap and being able to do this together
so that was a skill at the end of one of
the trees and basically what clar does
is he like goes up for the high five and
then you decide you want to melee me
back all right then uh now we both get
bonuses to health regeneration and fire
rting stuff that's right that's right if
I melee you back we actually get bonus
is because we enjoy each other but if I
want to like hey up ignore you what you
screw you guys and then uh only I get
the bonus and I go off and hell it's
best to like clap trap apparently uh so
clap trap new playable class in uh
obviously Borderlands the Pre-Sequel
we've got more on the game coverage
coming on gamespot.com so keep a lookout
for that here from PX
Prime
and we're back live here at PX Prime at
sector G where we are running two hours
of live show demos talks with people who
are out and about at packs and generally
having the whole packs experience right
from the couch IND your living room I'm
Chris Waters and joining me on stage now
is Jake Casal from 17 bit he's a project
lead and art lead on Galax Z Jake thanks
for coming man thank you uh Galax Z you
guys are on the show floor people can
play the game uh how's the reaction been
for it's been fantastic you know this is
our third packs but it's the first time
the game is like solid it's running
clean we had a couple technical snafus
but last night we got the final solid
build so we're good now nice uh we're in
the Sony Booth as well as in the ity
mega Booth uh we've got six playable
stations and it's just going off
fantastically we're getting a lot of
great feedback and watching people just
really enjoy the game and we're trying
to get the word out that it's not just a
traditional shooter there's a lot more
to this game and so uh exhibitions like
this and getting to talk to the press
and stuff is really how we get that
message out that's a great way to do it
and you know we've seen you guys at
packs before but this game is further
along than ever before and it's a a
thing of beauty to see in action so
let's Jump Right In and uh give folks a
taste and you said you know you look at
it right away it looks kind you your
mind puts it in a certain genre sure but
uh there's a lot more going on here so
set the stage for us so there was a uh
you're it's a spaceship game it looks
like a spaceship game spaceship shooter
arcade games I grew up playing arcade
games I love them uh the story here is
that you uh you're kind of this Fleet
goes out for a big treaty with evil
Imperials it's a ruse it's a giant
Ambush everyone gets killed the entire
fleet is wiped out except for your
Flagship you were the last literally the
last remaining pilot out you guys snuck
out they're still looking for you
they're all over the place um you are
the last guy remaining and you're kind
of going out looking through these
little planetoids and these deric wrecks
looking for supplies anything to kind of
keep your chances of survival going so
you're on the Run yeah she's going to
send me in every time I start a new game
I'm going to jump in it's a Rog likee so
every time I die I kind of start from
the beginning okay but as you play
through you're going to unlock more and
more stuff that's going to start being
stocked in the shop uh stock yes I made
that right you got it uh so I'm going to
start in here there's a couple things I
can buy to start off this game to kind
of get me uh a little bit more
competitive and did these credits carry
over from your previous playthrough or
do you sort of have a stock starting
credit at at the beginning of every run
it usually you start with no cash but
you find these things called crash coins
out in the world which you can use to
buy a couple things at the beginning of
every game like most Rogue likes kind of
start you off at at zero again yeah we
let you if you had a good run you can
buy a couple toys to start your your
game off with so I'm going to jump in
the hanger here and take off
off this mic is G me grief but I'm okay
um so the trick is like as soon as you
see this like again it looks like a top
down shooter right and most top down
Shooters are you know you're just kind
of being Dr Along by the teeth and you
just sort of brainlessly shooting all
the enemies you can find yeah dodging
the bullet hell that is coming at you
exactly this is much more of an open
world e sort of experience it's all
Newtonian physics driven so you can see
here I've got complete that's my
favorite kind of physics I've got
complete control over the ship um the
controls are really lyrical I mean just
flying around as you get better at it
flying backwards and zipping through
things uh it feels fantastic there's
really a lot to it and you can tell I
mean I'm sure the sense is heightened
when you actually have your hands on the
controller but you can tell by looking
at the shift that there's some inertia
there that you know you're not just
turning on a dime and going to wherever
the controller you know ex you have to
Incline the analog stick there's a lot
of sort of uh responsibility for the
player really I mean there's a lot to it
this really is sort of a tactical dog
fighting game we've teamed up with a new
company called sentient that's doing
middleware for AI the AI in this game I
would put up against anything I put up
against Far Cry put up against Halo it
really is that level of of competition
uh so you know it's more of an adventure
game than anything I mean it's kind of
like a super metroid but like imagine
Halo Combat I mean I really to think
this is Halo in 2D actually it's closer
to far cry because like there's enemies
that are out in patrols you don't know
where they're going to be everything's
procedurally generated so every time I
come in here I don't know who I'm going
to come up against or where you can see
these early warning arrows here there's
a bunch of Imperials off to my right and
a bug off to my left
all the enemy factions are also at war
with each other conveniently so if you
get kind of ganged up on the best thing
to do is run and find some enemies of
your enemies and just allow this join in
the melee that's these guys don't see me
coming they've got eyes and ears Vision
cones you can tell they know I'm here
now I'd say so I'd say that missile
barrage sort of kicked them off yeah I
woke them up I had a good shot there a
lot of these guys the uh these are the
Imperials their their Shields are kind
of closer to the traditional Halo style
the pirate Shields they don't actually
until they are in combat so if you can
manage to sneak up behind them before
they know you're there you can get the
head in hi boys roll through here so you
see I've got exactly sneak up on them
that time did you Jake but sometimes you
got to go in guns blazing it so you have
a shield as well yeah I've got a shield
as well that recharges my health is not
recharged unless I find a rare health
pack but uh you know in the in the vein
of something like Spelunky or in most of
the Rogue lights like recovering your
health is is not it's not guaranteed
this is a tough game you're meant to die
a lot I mean it really is sort of an
arcade simulator better to preserve your
health than to count on recovering it
you can see me bouncing off walls here
this is not a game that punishes you for
for bouncing into walls it's is a very
physical game it's all about the
Tactical combat and it's very it's it's
violent I mean you're slamming around
and slamming through these guys locking
on with some missiles letting them have
it dodging their shots I have this Juke
I can jump out of the game playay I was
going to say you just like jumped out of
the 2D plane there right yeah no it's
totally cheating but uh it is limited
and it makes for fantastic dog fighting
so hey if it's in the game it's part of
the strategy chasing down the last dude
uh so he'll run off and he'll actually
call for backup if his Shields are down
and there's other guys in charge they'll
they'll kind of try to interject
themselves let him recharge his Shields
while he gets his health back um they'll
run off for for backup you know they'll
kind of Mark my position and call in for
reinforcements I mean it really is sort
of a modern combat simulator dressed as
this classic old school shooting game so
we're getting a lot of really fantastic
feedback from the show for here this is
a kind of his nickname junkyard dog he
is a sound like a Mech with a like an
energy sword an eny it's an imperial
Mech theyve they've taken and hijack
he's going to fight that bug off for me
and I'm going to get back in his face
here this guy he's got a melee weapon so
I'm going to just stay away from him
yeah he's really trying to close in on
you these exploding barrels and stuff
are actually really dangerous you can
set them off and they'll bouncing off
everything yourself yeah ah backfired
that backfired I'm out of boost I'm out
of warp my Shields are down Now's the
Time to just run I don't want to engage
I want to run there's my Shields are
coming back okay now I'm going to go
take this guy out you you are still very
much on fire I just want you to know
that I've noticed yeah I'm also I've got
eight missiles left all right his
Shields are down I'm going to let him
have it while it counts here W was a
good fight these guys uh you know like I
said not Ming around this is a this is a
tough game it's it's a game where you
die a lot and it's not about memorizing
anything it's about being constantly
presented with with new challenges new
you know objectives and and territories
and just sort of learning how to fight I
mean it really is learning how to be a
tactical comater now how how much how
sort of out I guess
doing a little stealth now uh which are
those I mean those things are red
they're going to explode right all the
exploding barel speaking the speaking my
language here I'm trying to find I would
like to all here we go okay so this bug
I'm going to just drag him with me into
all these guys they'll attack him and
he'll probably start chopping on them
you see that doing my job for me I'm
going light this thing up oh I
missed oh we going to get him oh he's in
the blast zone yeah I think you put a
whammy on one of them with that TNT box
can hide I mean a lot this is like GTA I
love it they call it the scramble you
know when you're running from the cops
and you're freaking out you're just
trying to get out you just need to get
around a corner real quick get a little
Shield sight with him the problem is
they're not cheating at all they really
their AI is so good they'll see which
trajectory you headed off at where they
think you turned you know they'll call
for backup and they'll go in inspect
your position see he thinks he last saw
me up there he's going to go look for me
up there unfortunately for him he's by
himself now and I am going to out gun
him and yeah you want to so so isolating
enemies uh pulling enemies into
situations so it's a lot about
positional management and sort of
Battlefield management
not it really is you know this this
fight that you're dealt with every time
you're always going to be out manned
you're always going to be outgunned so
you got to think tactically
strategically using the environment to
your advantage using the enemies to your
advantage uh you know trying to distract
them with you know getting into fights
with themselves try to find how I'm
getting down here so I do have a full
map think and so as this map uh
generated a new each play yeah so these
these are all completely procedurally
generated every time
um you know it's going to be a new
challenge every time and those will kind
of change organically too as you play
through the game and you start to play
at some of the higher difficulty levels
you know the the way that the structures
uh are generated will change a bit you
know it gets when you're playing at a
high level it becomes a very different
game like you literally do not want to
engage with everybody like you're just
running trying to stay alive while this
absolute you know huge gunfights that
you're in are going on see where am I
going here I think here maybe up
here there we go and so what are these
uh are the the items that are sparking
are those just sort of environmental
they're environmental environmental
hazards that will uh basically take out
your uh Shields Oh They'll they will
take out your Shields yeah but you can
use them by like you know bumping them
into enemies having them uh lose their
Shields as well in one of the previous
encounters you were kind of pushing that
block towards the where the you know
where it was going to go down uh do you
guys have any kind of like tow hook or
cable to or or sort of push beam to sort
of lean into that kind of strategy
something like that yeah um there's
quite a few passive abilities um a lot
of different powerups stuff like that
that are that are coming online a lot of
that stuff we're not showing just yet uh
we're kind of finishing up some of the
uh design of some of that stuff but uh
there will be a lot more interaction
with the environment in general so I'm
almost done now so these guys that probe
got away and he went and called on my
position so now I've got a problem yeah
that's a lot of I'm going to get some
room between me and these guys the guys
look kind of small but there's a lot of
them on the Swarm yeah and oh and they
got a big boy too okay I'm going to
leave now that's my cue to leave
unfortunately a few in shots on the way
out and let's see if I can set up any
ambushes here this is good if I let this
thing go I just missed that going to C
cuz there was also a tank down there
maybe that'll
Cascade oh so you see those those alert
things pop in to just like give you the
give you the heads out here comes the
party all right so again I like to
separate these guys from their main crew
take out the probes and stuff they don't
really have any weapons but they're
really good at at being really fast
keeping up with you and kind of calling
your position con tracking you so that
Big Bopper over here can and this is the
Imperial version of the sort of pirate
hijack the Pirates steal these things
and and refit them themselves uh they're
you know they kind of tweak the engines
and stuff and make them a little crazy
so they're less stable these things are
pretty mean the Sentinels are one of the
meanest enemies in the game they don't
screw around so here's my warp out
Beacon the problem is I need to stay in
here for a couple seconds without
getting hit and they're going to make it
really hard for me with that big melee
unit around that's not going to be easy
so I'm going to maybe kick off some of
these things and
run cuz this is bad how many seconds do
you need like five it's like 5 Seconds
yeah there's no way these guys all have
physics on every single shot they have
they're going to knock me around this
guy with the sword is not screwing
around I'm out of missiles I'm out of
opportuni you got your work cut out for
you I do have a work cut out for me this
is uh yeah I would really wish I had
some more missiles right now but I'm
going to I'm going to take him out
anyway I got him you got some you got
you got you got some moves you see how
fast he is I mean he's he's breaking
contact like he knows he's being fired
on it's not like he's dumb I mean this
is like you know seriously Cutting Edge
AI he is like you know getting out of
the line of fire making sure he's got
got time to recharge sh Rees and then
coming back at you troublingly start
what I can do though is I can pop this
thing take his
shield so are you yeah are you trying to
take out that he's going to get me this
is bad could you make a run for the exit
I mean there around the corner maybe I
can get up here and warm out in time I
missed oh no shot it curse you newon
phys go go go go go no that's not going
to happen so close jeez this is crazy
all right I'm going to just take this
guy out cuz he's killing me
got to get one of them down and I didn't
uh I stupidly didn't buy any weapon
power ups at the beginning of the game
so I'm basically operating on my super
base level laser here trying to take
what power-ups did you buy at the
beginning of the game I think I bought a
missile expansion and a speed
expansion well the speed has helped you
out a little bit he's not going to let
me out man oh I believe in you you can
do it Jake I'm wondering if uh you know
there's been a lot of changes lately I'm
wondering if the shields aren't a little
overcooked on this guy because I feel
like I've earned a death by now there's
one there you got one down you got plus
eight missiles for that kill did you
yeah I just saw it pop up Onre yeah
there we go okay have some of this
friend I got something for you there you
go and with his Shields down I'm going
to get in as close as I can land him
there got there it is all right nicely
done man okay here we go now let's get
out of here so you can see you know
defending these things are generally the
the toughest guys in this stage are
going to be defending your warp out zone
so securing The Landing zone is a is a
[__] and these guys are really smart
they're hard
and uh it's a challenge and I just lost
my video oh no Demo's over we're we're
shut it down okay good that worked out
just in time that's the perfect way to
end it you succeeded you got out that
was good my heart's pounding a little
bit you know uh it's good to demo while
you're uh running for your life so
absolutely that took a a little more
than 10 minutes is that about the
average sort of length for so there's
there's about four or five we're still
working on this but there's going to be
four five or six of those in a row to
beat the season okay and when you beat
the season you sort of beat the game and
that opens up the next season which is
going to have some new story stuff he
going to have some new unlocks and
there's six seasons overall there's a
mini story arc over each one and there's
a massive story arc over the entire
process all right Jake well when are you
guys targeting for uh Galaxy's release
and what systems are you aiming to bring
it out on so uh we're working with Sony
the pup fun group we'll be launching uh
this holiday kind of post holiday
probably winter time on PS4 and VA and
then shortly therea on PC very cool Jake
thank you so much for showing off Galaxy
uh folks that's coming this way coming
your way this winter on Playstation
platforms now we're going to take a look
at a surprising announcement from
developer harmonics it's a game called
the city sleep sleeps and it's not
really what you might expect from the uh
rhythm game Titan that they are let's
check it
out hey everyone welcome to P Prime I'm
Peter Brown I'm here joined by my friend
and my boss Randol Ramsey let's let's
let's not get too formal with each other
how are you I'm great man and I know
that you got a chance to go see a game
called a city sleeps that's right it's
the new one from harmonics and it's kind
of a I guess a a weird Direction They
sort of like popped up with this game at
the start of packs and it's something
that you normally wouldn't expect for
them so it's a schmap yeah which as you
know people will know it's shooter M up
a bit of a bullet hell shooter I think
we're seeing some footage of it now uh
and um you know a couple of the guys
that worked on chroma uh which was that
shooter that you know the harmonics guys
were developing uh and talked about the
start of this year it was going to be
like a a rhythm based firsters shooter
uh so you know while they're working on
that and trying to retool and trying to
find out what they want to do with that
game uh you know they had a few folks
you know do a side project um and you
know taking a lot of the stuff that they
learned from you know um you know trying
to do a shooter within something like
chroma into a bullet hell shooter like
this and you know like the two lead guys
in this are apparently are sort of
massive fans of the genre and as you can
see right now it's um a lot of bullets
on the screen so yeah I mean we talked
about harmonics and you you brought it
up with chroma but I need to know what's
going on here cuz they're known for
their games that incorporate music and
rhythm is that a part of the game play
itself or is music just sort of
emphasized throughout the game so so
music is heavily emphasized because
you're right it is harmonics a harmonics
title so you know they're always going
to be about the music um it's not
similar to anything else I've done in
that you're not actually beat matching
so you're not you know you're not
shooting to create a beat or anything
like that so there is like you know a
strong sort of like hip hop is
soundtrack that goes throughout it the
uh the level itself is sort of map to
you know matching
uh like the beats and Rhythm of the of
the music itself but you know it's not
actually like a like a specific sort of
like note matching thing like you would
have had in a rock band or you know any
other thing that they've done in the
recent past uh the shim of genre has a
really strong following in Japan it it's
not as big in North America no it's not
uh we had a game come out about two
years ago called cinora that was made by
Hungarian studio with Grasshopper
manufacturer from Japan and that was a
really nice mix on the the sort of schmu
uh you know genre but uh you one thing
wondering is does this game have
hardcore appeal cuz harmonics doesn't
typically make games for people that are
fans of schms it's it's interesting you
say that actually because you know like
the two lead guys for this apparently
are sort of huge uh schmu fan so you
know they did not want to actually dumb
it down for more of a western audience
so you know they are you know trying to
make sure that this has the same type of
appeal uh as you know like a really
hardcore Japanese schar so what we're
seeing on the screen here I believe is
actually just on easy difficulty okay so
um you know it it it will be you know it
can get a lot more challenging so you
know in higher difficulties you know
like the the boss you know bullet
patterns will be different uh and as
typical for a schmap you see that little
um the blue dot in the middle of your
character Poe there that's actually your
hitbox uh so you know you just have to
be uh really accurate you know with how
you actually maneuver and and the thing
that's glowing green right now there's
are I think you know two of the I guess
more unique things that you know
harmonic is trying to to put into this
game so po uh she's a dream Exorcist and
your main character in the game of has
access to these three um sort of like
ghost Powers uh that she can deploy at
any time so you know one uh will give
her health so um it's disappeared right
now but the screen before like that
green thing that was uh that was sort of
like pulsing uh would give out pulses of
like green that you can catch to um to
boost your health uh and another one is
like for attack and another one is like
boost your defense so um you can sort of
switch that out on the Fly and you can
see the sort of the menu That's popping
up around her um you can like choose
which ones that you can actually um you
want to do um to to deploy so we're
seeing a boss battle now and I got to
say Peter you know I'm not a huge shum
up guy so you know you're much more
familiar with the genre like from what
you're seeing here like you know does it
is it really evocative of you know lots
of Japanese titles uh at least in terms
of the the Don maku like you know the uh
the the curtain of bullets as it sort of
referred to like yeah you definitely
have those elements and for an easy mode
it's pretty interesting I'm curious to
see how the hitbox is going to change
I'm assuming if the game is a higher
difficulty setting that hit box is going
to be a little bit larger um but as it
is yeah I mean it does seem to have you
know the the elements that you'd look
for it it is a little bit unusual in
that you can move anywhere on the screen
and fire in any direction but uh but
that's sort of an interesting element uh
it's it's curious to see what harmonics
can do with this because they're fans of
the genre but it's their first time
doing it but I think they might bring
something really interesting and what's
really interesting too is you know the
development of this has been uh quite
unique I guess for the studio so you
know they're trying to do a little bit
of a double find type thing in which
they've all broken off into small teams
trying to iterate really quickly trying
to come up with game Concepts and just
seeing what actually sort of flies and
sticks and what's got to appeal and this
is the first one really that you know so
utilizing that new model and it's coming
out to um PC and Mac via steam uh have
any dates in mind no um I think they've
got a date for October I don't have the
exact date but we can sort of update
that with later all right well that's
City sleeps by harmonics coming to PC
and Mac pretty soon stay tuned to
gamespot.com we have a whole lot more
packs coverage on the
way
yeah I'm super hot so obviously PX Prime
is a lot about games not just video
games tabletop games card games all the
kind of games your little brain can
think up but it's also about the people
who are here the events the panels uh
just the whole creative strata that
comes down the line when people come
together to celebrate the stuff they
love so at that in mind I'd like to
introduce my two guests to my right here
Mikey Newman and Chris stob gentlemen
thank you for joining me no problem I
almost did not make it here on time you
are you're here with plenty of time to
spare but you were running from the
gearbox panel yeah we had the main
theater panel down on it's like second
in University year so so what is what is
a gearbox pan so you're a writer for
gearbox yeah or and and more y I
technically my my title is Chief
creative Champion Chief creative
Champion which means not a lot no do you
shorten it at all do you say like a tric
it's come up do you try it
do you go 3C or C
cubed wait where where you at where you
at Okay C cubed so yeah we did the we
did the gearbox panel that was super fun
uh Randy Pitchford did the Ice Bucket
Challenge on stage oh wow which you know
maybe could be worn out it's welcome a
little bit though it's great cause
they're making a lot of money doing it
uh he actually laid down on his back in
a kitty pool oh wow so full like and
they they dumped it super slow from his
feet all the way up um and he I've never
seen him freak out so physically before
he was like it was it was actually kind
of terrifying we're like are you okay is
it do you need do you need a blanket do
we need a towel we just covered him in
towel they have to have Medics on staff
for that type of thing we did not that
was actually probably the one thing we
did that is incredibly irresponsible
Randy pitford come on man but for a good
cause it was a great cause great cause
uh so you've been doing you were doing
some uh some gearbox stuff here but you
also delivered packs keynote and it
talks to me like Keynotes differ widely
from packs to packs the sort of the
format changes the speakers change uh
what what was your situation like what
you what' you deliver well I uh cuz
Robert coup was the one that asked me
originally and he sent me an email and
he's like hey do you want to Keynote a
packs MH and I said of course right I
mean that's awesome yeah uh and I had
really thought about was going to say at
that time um and uh he's like well which
one do you want to do and I thought it
was was going to be packed South cuz I'm
from Texas anyway uh nope I was just
like well PX Brown is my favorite and he
said lock it in so yeah for like six
months I guess I've been thinking about
it and I it I'm sure we've all noticed
that over the last month two months it's
it's gotten to a a riled up situation
out there in our industry and I wanted
to I wanted to go on stage and and kind
of try to start bringing this back
together a call for sanity and uh the
the main point was just about spreading
Joy so I like those things sanity Joy
those are like on my top list of things
they do go together the VIN diagram
overlap yeah so the gaming sort of
connection for you Mikey uh is through
gearbox is through Borderlands actually
before I'm we'll talk to you in a second
Chris but we have to roll this interview
that I dug up the first time you and I
met I was telling him about this oh my
gosh we met in 2009 when Borderlands was
uh just first announced at E3 uh we're
going to get our our interview up here
and take a look at us from about 5 years
ago this the same maybe my second E3
interviewing and yeah there it is time
cap looks like Matt Damon this was a
really fun interview look at those
glasses what do I think of from space
what am I
doing oh man like Google Glass without
any of the electronics in it he's just a
fashion he's fashion forward you know
yeah it's Google ass glasses what I I
think my favorite thing to come out of
that was a user comment that said we
looked like school days
friends which I I guess is cool that's
actually really funny considering part
of my keynote was actually just about
this story from fifth grade oh really so
I I feel like we brought it up I can't
believe you dug that up that's so
awesome oh my God you were in fifth
grade there that was amazing yeah no I
was like Borderlands really excited
recess come play it right I got my
crackers I got my juice I'm ready to go
uh so you guys collaborate also outside
of the Gearbox Software realm and that's
uh on your website or I mean I guess you
guys sort of
your.com yeah I'm a cartoonist uh I work
out of the penny arcade offices I've
known them for a long time M uh I did
the uh intro animations for Acquisitions
Incorporated that stuff every year which
was a huge hit last night a pleasure I
couldn't attend it's it's horrifying we
had a panel we had a panel had our show
it and Acquisitions Incorporated for
those who don't know it's the uh
Dungeons and Dragons live the celebrity
game yeah every year uh so but you're a
cartoonist people can check out I mean
I'm sure people have seen this maybe you
know they Big Ups to Frank and com Frank
and O getting a little extra play Let's
get that manly style under $50 can we
shop now actually can we yeah can we
just go through give me some of that
they will do it don't don't tempt them I
saw it hover uh so this thing's been
going for a little while now yeah You'
been in this how long I've been uh
chainsaw suit I've done since like 2008
but I've been at cartoonist since 2000
professionally professionally as a pro
in as much as anybody is a professional
do you go to ComicCon ever yeah I went
to San Diego Comic Con for uh 10 years I
have stopped going and my first year was
this year and it was just I had the sad
Charlie Brown clo Cloud following me
like you were like all Chris I'm hanging
out on boats wish you were here a lot of
boat action this year boats here San
Diego one of them's real big they put
planes on it yeah one of the larger
boats I've seen yeah actually San Diego
is a boat uh I did not that's amazing
hash tweet us hash San Diego is a vote
for your chance to
win a dinner with Chris Waters it's a
hashtag it's got to be true it's true
that is what brings all things into
being these days uh but chainsaw suit
you guys have you've got the comic there
but you guys also do a podcast we do a
we have a podcast and a YouTube channel
the podcast is chainsaw /p podcast we've
done as of last night's 70 episodes
though it's not up yet uh how would you
describe the show Chris it's talk it's
comedy and uh it's it's well sponsored
as well yeah except we are our own
sponsors sponsor one of my favorite
things about that we throw to fake
commercials constantly yeah uh what were
the ones we did cuz we had some for the
panel that we made literally in an hour
no I did one for purel retribution it's
no longer about hand sanitization no
it's about making the germs themselves
sick oh really because we've lost the
battle Yeah it's over for us all we can
do now is strike at them from our
decline just attrition at this point
yeah and then and then mine was it was
for the Long John Silver's fish plank
enchilada The Long John s's fish plank
enchilada which as we go cuz there's
like we can make fun of our product but
we actually just did this thing about
how the guy I ate it too much and he was
communicating through a Ouija board with
a fish blank enchilada on it to his dog
cuz that's what you can expect from
chainsaw suit yeah we also have a
YouTube channel SL chainsaw suit
original what do you do on the YouTube
uh well we animate some of the
commercials uh you have a show you're
doing a series called movies with Mikey
which is check that well received which
it's pretty straightforward there's
movies there's
Mikey if I if I may may I is that
reductive I don't want to wa Chris
please feel this uh it actually goes in
line with your keynote when you talk
about positivity enjoy there's a lot of
review stuff on YouTube that's just like
taking movies apart and finding all the
negative stuff you love these movies and
you're reviewing them and giving a lot
of information about why and part of it
like finding hidden gems uh a good one
to start with with the Last Action Hero
review if you can find that because you
would think well I even I didn't
remember it being as as baller as it was
but the in the last section here of you
just to give you a preview of what I do
here uh I talk about Schindler's list
and the symbolism in that movie and then
I talk about the symbolism in Last
Action Hero and what starts as a joke
you realize no it's actually deeper and
more effective in Last Action Hero than
it is in Schindler's List Schindler's
List great movie Very surface level it's
like oh she's got a red sweater I don't
know if I would have led with that
example it sounds like
a retrospect but you know you get you
get deep on cinematic Theory who knows
where it's going to take you # 911 was a
boating
accident which is also one of the
[__]
yeah that one will not get you dinner
with Chris Waters unfortunately uh oh
there's there's Michelle oh look at it
Last Action Hero I was actually pleased
to hear you extoling the virtues of a
long kiss good night as well yes oh my
god well these are two uh uh because we
have Shane black wrote this film and
Shane black also wrote The Long Kiss
good night which I love I think it's
Samuel Jackson's greatest film uh roller
ball is not Samuel Jackson's greatest
film nor is he in it he was like a key
grip I think but yeah it's it's it's a
show where I get to celebrate movies my
my next review is actually Water World
and that was a requested one oh yeah cuz
some of it's like can you accept the
challenge of the film and Water World I
realized something really crazy just to
break you off a little preview all of
their costumes are like if you look at
Dennis Hopper in the movie He plays this
very surface level villain but he has
glasses turned sideways to make the eye
patch for his missing eye it's implied
that those are his glasses because he
has trouble seeing things like from a
distance and I was like so when you
actually look at all these characters
like the guy with the six-pack plastic
rings for Cokes and stuff made an invest
there's all these like stories in their
costumes yeah I'm going to reconstruct
this entire other Narrative of the movie
that actually exists Under The Not So
Awesome movie on top uh the upshot of
all this and you've also like written a
few novels is that you guys combined are
like this incredible creative Force like
not just in your professional lives but
also your personal lives obviously your
great friends and romantic lives your
romantic lives your you know
psychosexual lives the whole all levels
all the all the yungi and fragments well
I mean you you you have brood Hollow as
well which I would I would be remiss if
we didn't talk about a little bit oh
yeah that's right it's that's rudol
that's my most recent web comic effort I
did a Kickstarter for the first book
last year it did very well it's uh my
the shorthand pitch is Tintin Goes To
insouth Love but like a 1930 okay that's
where inmi it's coming back I've also
gone with 10 10 goes to Twin Peaks if
you need something a little just a
little maybe if you're a younger person
you don't know what ismith is they have
to know what it is well okay sorry if
you don't know know what cthulu is
that's that's right in there oh I
wouldn't show the new Comics though if
they pull it up yeah it's kind of
spoilery it's okay no it's fine don't
wor it's now faking us out with the com
you've lost control of this interview
Waters come on did I ever have it Mike
how are you and I'm okay with that you
good yeah I mean I'm excited to get out
to the Indie Mega Booth today uh play
some games there hopefully I've been
doing doing show stuff hosted a
civilization panel yesterday I am so
have you played it yet oh yeah dang it
I'm jealous Civ 5 is my favorite game of
all time I love it I love it I love it I
love it it's looking pretty cool uh but
I want to bring it back real quick to to
try to hold on to the last vestages of
control I have over the situation before
it just all spins out and well we're
going to Stage guest to talk to
them they'll have to both sit there
though I think cuz I'm staying right
here yeah no
clearly it's the whole like the The
Staggering amount of sort of creative
like art and expression that you guys
both sort of output is inspiring to me
cuz you know I get to I get to do some
fun stuff here at Gamespot but like you
know I thought about like maybe like
writing a little book one time or maybe
like uh doing a YouTube series but you
know I feel like a lot of people there's
not that uh that initiative that hustle
that that drive to sort of start
creating the thing that they are
daydreaming about or you guys it's you
have to you do it because you love it
and then it doesn't matter whether or
not it succeeds or fails I if it even if
it failed you're still doing it because
you loved it you're still doing it just
to attack like in a collaborative way
sure yeah cuz I've done a lot of side
projects with with a few different
people and I remember when we originally
cuz we both lived in Dallas for a long
time I now you live in in you went to LA
and then Seattle but I didn't know I
didn't know him in Dallas at the time we
did not know each other at all um and
you were com cuz we were doing a a show
at PA that was like two and a half years
ago or whatever right um you were coming
to pick me up and I was I was worried
cuz I was I I'd heard Chris was an
a-hole like I've been told that and I
was like oh here we go we got out of the
car like down the street to get sushi I
mean we it was like a two-minute drive
and we're like hey you want to be best
friends you want to cuz it was like it
was crazy collab you hear me yeah and
that person was wrong about me no they
weren't I actually I actually am an
a-hole I'm sorry just really good at
faking it sorry sorry Dad it just turns
out he's just your kind of a-hole I mean
you know everyone's an a-hole a
little I think we we consistently set a
bar for each other especially when it
comes to Comedy and even even like the
positivity in comedy cuz that's always
been our our our slant is like cuz
people like don't don't punch down punch
up and we're like What if we didn't
punch anyone what if we what if we but
what if we also punch laterally what if
we also punched ourselves yeah yeah I
mean it's s we I mean we punched some
brand like tji Fridays and Guy Fier you
know we don't feel as bad about that you
guys taking Digs at Long John Silvers
earlier I mean that was some they no the
fish plank diagonal the fish plank at
gelada they take the the fish plank
American cheese Hush Puppy batter and
they deep fry it's the the fish it's off
menu no it's not real okay it I wish it
was I don't we fish because we love I
don't know about fish
places it's not my area of expertise
that's okay there's time to learn and
grow I think calling L Jong fish place
is maybe a little strong there's fish in
that chain somewhere the supply chain
you got to go back far enough it's all
right yeah it's it's in it evokes fish
at least maybe it's fish fishes fishine
fish
style so having a creative sort of
someone to bounce stuff off of someone
to collaborate with is that a is that a
sort of a way that's been it's been
obviously it's been gratifying for you
guys guys do you think that that's a
sort of a powerful way to kind of give
yourself a little bit more energy do you
get get energy from each other like
dedic like to claim that time during
your day I'm going to take this one I I
am a very funny person but I'm also the
lowest possible energy person and I'm
kind of the highest I used this really
silly metaphor to describe us yesterday
I'm going to say it it's cheesy but
accurate but cheesy uh if you have two
knives and you're trying to use them
separately eventually they'll Dole but
but if you take both knives and
constantly sharpen them off of each
other they're better knives but the
knives grow to hate each other they
cannot stand each other there's just a
lot of yeah a lot of tension that
develops between thetive knife sounds
like not a great thing one of those
knives moves out of the state even
though you know you hadn't met at that a
bummer you got to sort of track it back
no I'm a big fan of collaborative humor
and I think that I to go out by myself
somewhere I don't know if it would play
as well like I need somebody to play off
of well even at the table cuz this is uh
we have the ch gra a Mike new chainsaw
suit table out in uh bandland if you're
here come see us Y come get a limited
edition chainsaw suit print but it's so
it's it's amazing of course but I'm
saying like when you if you're alone at
a con and a table it's nowhere near as
as fun as just sitting around with your
best friend and signing stuff and it's
like wow this is amazing so enjoy
yourself yeah
and listen listen this a love seat for
two you know and I'm happy to just be
near it's just the right width all right
we we're coming to the end of this
conversation situation yeah let's do the
let's do the rundown what do you want
what do you want some viewers to to see
to do to uh to check out come out if
you're here come out see us in bandland
otherwise you can find us at chainsaw
suit.com subscribe to our podcast chaina
suit original on YouTube uh uh we're
both very handsome you can look at us
visually uh Borderlands the prequel
coming out this October please check
that out yeah uh it's awesome it's
actually really awesome it's pretty fun
I got play clap trap as the viewers saw
earlier I'm I'm fairly certain I can say
it's my favorite Borderlands experience
now it's added enough it's it's it's
added so much to it it's it's rounded it
out I really enjoy butt stomp is what is
what you're gestur really I'm just
saying you can butt Stomp and shoot acid
at at can I can I give it a shot today I
haven't played it yet I haven't tried it
yet yeah
oh take him off to play Borderlands
Mikey Newman Chris D thank you guys so
much for chatting talking packs
hopefully R you guys later sometime go
get a chainu print band please do all
right folks uh we are going to go I
think just like right over here maybe
talk to Danny O dwire and Drew scandin
is that right or are you just misleading
me grossly it's going to happen let's go
check in with those guys when we back up
here with some more game demos I think
Shadow of Mordor coming up soon stay
with
us hey what's up everyone Danny OWI here
and Drew scanland the uh the duo of alt
F1 uh delighted to be here at sector G
the home of uh Gamespot Giant bom and of
course uh everyone's favorite Formula 1
podcast alf1 that's right how are you
enjoying pack so far J that's good
you're leaving soon yeah yeah I got a
4:00 flight you're going to grab a
you're going to grab some food from
these these wonderful this beastro of
free food and dedic is right here on 720
Pine Street it's here just follow the
signs it says sector G outside eat all
this free food for sector G yeah there
you go there you go packs is not just
about free food though Drew or Formula 1
race cars also about video games that's
right did you play any today I did thank
you for serving that up I played a video
game called n Plus+ tell me about it
tell you about what n++ n Plus+ is video
game did you play any of the old n games
I did I actually took a class uh in
college where we made n plus levels for
a project really yeah mine was awesome
wow that's one of those hippie colleges
right yeah you seea
yeah yeah so the first one old Flash
game came out in 2006 uh 2008 was the
Xbox Live arcade game n plus was
brilliant I loved it real hard single
player I did Co-op one of my friends we
played the whole game through uh I I had
something like 10 and some 50 levels
maybe n Plus+ has 1,000 levels that's a
lot of I didn't know that 1,000 that's a
lot I know it's not just one dude well
there was like two a guy and a girl made
it before and now they got a bunch of
more people making it it's coming out
next year early apparently um all those
levels they're doing a competition today
actually if you're at PX at 3 3: p.m.
they're doing a competition to win a
PlayStation 4 that's fun that is fun
it's coming out PS4 first I hope it
comes out on PC and stuff afterwards do
you do I or will you play it on your PS4
I don't have a PS4 you could go back to
UCLA they probably have some you can
make more levels you guys got any PS4s
yeah they're making that whole level
sharing system as well so apparently
that's why it's taking a little bit of
time it's been like eight years put the
video game out I actually actually
majored an in Plus+ I don't know if you
that that's pretty good nice work
speaking of video games you played Halo
2o that's right I did that hot new
release is that the only game you played
at Fox that is literally the only game
well only video game I played the years
of war board game oh really which is not
great played that with Ian and uh Pascal
yeah not great have you I I haven't
touched any of the board game stuff was
it any good it's terrible great hear
that Cliff or whoever makes Gears of War
anymore Don Matt no everyone's gone
video games are dead everyone's left uh
what did you think of Halo too Drew uh
it's it's first of all Danny it is the
Master Chief Collection it is an
HD uprising of Halo 2 well it's actually
of all of them but Halo 2 is like the
new the new business of it but I played
lockout okay the classic Halo 2 map
lockout uh in glorious 60 frames a
second which is probably the weirdest
part because I don't think I think those
games were 30 before so it's kind of
jarring to see that um but it's still I
was able to just drop right back into
Halo 2 mode and it feels it feels great
and it looks great too what else is in
that collection it's all that obviously
single player and and multiplayer from
Halo 2 but there's a bunch more stuff
right yeah as far as I know it is Halo 1
through 4 all in HD and all the
multiplayers all of the master chief
games all of the master Chiefs so no
ODST no ODST no reach okay that's fair
enough no no no Halo Wars no Spartan ops
Oh the all the best ones I left out know
all units what the hell is that it's
from Halo Wars okay okay that's fair
enough have you played anything else
when you're wandering around or seen
anything else that was of Interest did
you go into the mega Booth uh I did yeah
I toured around it a little bit um I'm
still looking forward to apotheon what's
that it's that game that looks like um
Greek pottery art okay yeah it looks it
looks amazing what do you do in this
video game it's a side scroller jump
around kind of brawler fight dudes up in
the mega Booth yeah it's in the mega
Booth there's so much stuff there youd
spend like most we just had g z on the
stage earlier today uh that's coming out
in January thankfully soon uh I played
uh have you seen never ending nightmares
no have not so that's the oh wait yes I
have it's that terrifying like sketch
kind of looking thing yeah that is
freaky yeah that's uh Matt Gillen back's
uh Kickstarter project he did earlier
this year um he's the guy who made
retrograde okay which uh was that sort
of uh you could play it with a guitar I
remember it was like a almost reverse
time shooter didn't do that that well it
did poorly actually and this is kind of
um his uh his his take on the experience
after that cuz he sort of suffers from
depression uh and it's a kind of a the
game is basically talking it's you're
meant to feel through playing the game
some of those feelings and it's really
weird because it's it's it's it's you've
got uh was it my my dragon cancer I
forget what's the name of that game the
it's right there I forget it's then
there's never ending nightmares and then
there's that tent with that experience
Oculus game where you go in drink tea
which was made in burning man so like
yeah so like the back of the Indie Mega
Booth is just this insane just go and
experience emotion Center yeah that's
always the most exciting booth at pack
so if you're if you're coming you should
go to the me mega Booth first did you
play that game with the the bomb
disposal Stu no I really really want to
like when Oculus comes out I'm hoping
that one is right there for me yeah uh
should we talk a little bit about the
rumble Rumble no you want to cut it off
you cut off cuz T was doing that
nonsense which means I just get to mix
signals who the hell knows who won The
Rumble do you want to spoil it for
people uh I mean it was streamed oh yeah
good point but you should watch it you
should watch that thing PS is all about
video games and F1 and Royal rumbling
and enjoy your flight home thank you ju
scanland thank you pleasure we're going
back to the stage Chris Waters wants to
talk about Shadow of Mordor one
Shadow he learns good work Danny uh all
right folks we do have Shadow of Mordor
ready to show you off here with the
these things that are stuck on my ear
joining me right here on stage at P
Prime is Bob Roberts lead designer on
the game from monolith software uh is it
monus software did I say that totally
wrong Productions Productions Bob
welcome to the stage thank you for
coming thanks for having me uh first but
before we get kicked off here uh do we
here in sector G do we have any Lord of
the Rings fans
here I would also be yelling but it
would get really loud cuz I have this
microphone thing uh I'm a huge fan and
during E3 uh you know we got to see a
lot of the game different sort of
aspects of it and you guys are showing
off letting people play here at the show
floor as well yeah that's right and we
had uh had some of you guys in the in
the studio just on Thursday to play the
same demo we're we're jumping very late
into the game so what you'll see here is
like uh pretty far into the story pretty
far into the sandbox you're powered up
quite a bit okay you got to the point
now where you're not just uh killing
everybody but you can start to choose
whether you want to dominate a guy make
him you know your soldier to fight for
you or if you want to just Harvest him
for the loot all right uh so let's take
a look right at it see if we're going to
dominate or harvest for loot or both or
all he getting killed right there oh
sorry somebody the cave rat so he's
going to drop a rune that you could pick
up and upgrade your weapon with we'll
see that's one of the war chief so that
was one of the big bosses that just got
taken down there this is actually from
the uh uh the Thursday uh event that you
guys were playing out at our studio
uhhuh and it looks like that was that
was the Warchief but he's got three
bodyguards and this guy right here is
actually actually uh one that they
dominated the blue there indicates that
he's dominated so this is their guy he
just became the new war chief and it it
looks like they're going to probably
send him on a mission I'm going to send
him to start mixing things up cuz your
goal here and this this sort of like uh
you know lineup of all these different
ORS is is the hierarchy that you've
worked your way through to get to the
war Chiefs exactly yeah and and all
these guys are Dynamic they're
procedurally generated so these are all
the bosses in this area but you're never
going to have the same bosses twice like
if you play the game a second time your
friends game 100 times in they're all
going to be different so in this case
they just uh they branded one of those
bodyguards so that they had a man on the
inside they went after his Warchief and
uh took him out so their guy takes over
and now they're sending him off on a
riot to start some chaos for them all
right so they're set you've set one more
Chief in action to to metal things up
with the other uh and now sort of
escaped to a glowing White Tower that's
right back in the open world here you
can fast travel between these towers
there this is part of the uh the Dual
protagonist character we've got you know
inhabiting the same body you've got
talion the ranger of the black Gates
who's killed right at the beginning of
the game but he's not allowed to die
he's brought back from death over and
over by Kell bmore who's The Wraith
inhabiting him who's the uh actually the
elf from the second age that forged the
rings of Power with Sauron so he's a
pretty powerful dude pretty powerful
dude and he's groundhog daying you in
like the worst way possible
exactly or a verb by the way or
hopefully the best way possible the best
way possible perhaps I mean maybe for
Italian's mental state it's not super
great but uh certainly for us it gives
us an awesome chance to romp around uh
this lovely looking Mordor which then
that's one of the more striking things
that I think for me you know coming into
it right away you know I I knew you guys
were in a different era than sort of
what I we've seen on in cinema of course
but Mordor is a very diverse
geologically geographically diverse
Place yeah I mean the the point at which
in the lore that we're kind of tackling
it uh sauron's actually been away from
Mordor for thousand of years so it's had
that time to kind of grow back and
become a beautiful Wild Frontier again
yeah turns out not having like the Lord
of all evil hanging out in you uh is
good for the complexion exactly so now
he's just coming back just starting to
industrialize and rip everything apart
again so we get a little window into the
fertile kind of the landscape where he
could still feed his armies before he
strips it bear where you just tried to
do a we just tried to do a stealth
attack but it turned out that that
character was invulnerable to stealth
that's right is that something you can
sort of Recon ahead of time or is that
just like going to be a random roll on
that enemy and whoops now you go to now
you got to get get loud if you if you
put the time in to strategize every
every boss has a weakness has some kind
of way you can exploit to to take him
out so you can grab the other Orcs in
the uh in the world and dominate them
and peer into their minds to get the
intel on guys and then study their
strengths and weaknesses so that's it's
something that keeps the game fresh too
the fact that these guys are all
procedural means they all get different
strengths and weaknesses every time you
play and you have different boss fights
and and so what you end up here like
this is the the the mechanism right you
go into their mind like that and then
you can find out about some of the other
captains and War Chiefs so let's say
you're a really excellent stealth player
there's going to be some of these guys
that are vulnerable to that and I am no
that definitely not but you'll always
bump into to somebody along the way
who's going to challenge that who's
going to be invulnerable to it and the
same was true about combat and ranged
and uh using the beasts that's another
big part of the sandbox is making just
chaos with the wildlife and that's we
were talking before the demo started
about the diff about the terms open
world and sandbox and the latter kind of
implies that really getting your hands
in there and messing around and like
sort of being able to influence things
in in ways to create unexpected
situations exactly yeah we we use both
terms for this game a lot because open
world clearly implies the like freedom
of movement and navigation explore where
you want and all that and that's
definitely the case here but we we also
like the term sandbox a lot because it's
just this this you know toy set it's got
all these little little bits and parts
that you start to feed into the systems
they start to play off of each other and
you can create all kinds of crazy
unexpected emergent moments that's
what's going to be the most fun for us
once we launch is it's the same thing
that made it fun to work on for years
you get crazy stories that you never
thought possible that just keep coming
up to surprise you I can't wait to watch
people's like stream videos and
screenshots see all the all the
shenanigans that ensue well speaking of
story what we're taking a look at now is
uh sort of a section from the story and
part of it that involves a familiar face
yeah so uh so this Mission here is uh
the first story Mission we've been
showing uh give you little glimpse into
what that part of the the game is like
actually the uh The Narrative of the
game is nonlinear as well it was uh
written by the lead designer writer on
Red Dead Redemption Christian canessa
red I love that game that was a huge win
for us to get him on board and work with
him on the structure and style so it's
also nonlinear like Red Dead uh but he
has a lot of fun uh fun characters to
work with and Gollum is a great one uh
it's actually very similar to Seth from
Red Dead but uh he's you know at this
point in the lore gollum's just had the
ring stolen from him from from the
filthy Trixie Bilbo and he's off into
Mordor in search of it this is where he
ends up in the lore at this time so
that's where we get to cross paths with
him and of course you're inhabited by
the maker of the Rings of power so you
have this deep connection to the you
know one of the Ring bearers golum oh
yeah uh so he's kind of leading you
around the environments uh he's trying
to find these artifacts these heirlooms
of kelmore that when you find them they
sort of jog his memory and help him
remember who he was and help him regain
his power so that that's the mission
we're showing here as you get uh
following Golem tracks going in and out
of the physical world and wraith world
to keep track of him and then work your
way into try and find one of these
artifacts and learn about kellmore okay
and then so so coming out of this by the
way that that orc what I mean what would
you is that like a that's a gr he's a
massive kind of super predator in Mordor
it's like twice the size of a troll
groud grow gr SM but with a G ah uh so
you know that's here actually this is a
good example of the ecosystem in action
you got the bait there it's gonna
attract some caragors who are like big
lion big cat type Predators but of
course that gets his attention too so
he's gonna come rushing in and start a
fight with them which gives you the
chance to sneak into his cave just jet
on by because no one wants to run into a
grow especially on a gr's home turf you
can see the cave here like this is
another part of the sandbox is you got
the mountains have these Cavern systems
and caves that you can explore find
Collectibles find crazy beasts in here
so we're going to sneak through here and
uh and eventually probably see him use
wraith world again to track Gollum and
also maybe find some artifacts pick up
some stories from the thousands of years
of layered history that have built up in
Mordor that's in there yeah are these
like growlings so these little guys
are yeah these guys if they get if they
escape if you don't get them before they
get back into their pits they'll come
back out with a crazy swarm and just
overwhelm you so a crazy swarm coming
out of the walls in a cave sounds like
my nightmare uh but you know definitely
a a neat sort of threat
because there there are a lot of diverse
threats to you I mean from the wildlife
to the sort of towering grags all the
all the diverse Orcs and all that it's
really there's really a lot of Nefarious
forces to deal with that's right and and
on top of the uh the sort of diversity
in the wildlife and and the basic Orcs
the fact that the Nemesis system is like
building all these different kind of
specific strengths and weaknesses means
those Orcs are pretty infinitely varied
as well that you got such a
array of of uh sort of strengths and
weaknesses to deal with to to strategize
around so this this is sort of going
between The Wraith world and the not
actual world not wraith World physical
world physical world there we go uh that
allows you to do do a little
investigation along this story line now
is this are these do these branches I
mean this sort of cave here is this a
part that you'll only sort of have
access to when you're taking on the
story or will you be able to come back
around to this place ended and we want
you to really have the freedom to
explore and do this stuff whenever you
want and the the story missions take
place inside the open world but of
course there's a lot of other things
going on in that in that space beyond
just that kind of the character The
Narrative so you know you'll always be
able to grab those Collectibles to deal
with uh the things that would be there
otherwise and maybe if you spot
something you just didn't have time to
get CU you were busy on the story
Mission you can try and remember come
back and pick it up later all right well
certainly lots to do in the open World
sandbox of Mordor in Shadow of Mor
uh
Bob we've we've seen some good chunks of
this game and they're they're just
wetting my appetite for more uh when
when are you guys releasing the game
what's the release date and on what
platforms it's coming out on September
30th on PS4 Xbox One PC 360
PS3 fantastic can't wait that's like a
month away yeah are you excited to
launch this thing we are all very pumped
yeah awesome Babble thank you so much
for coming on S Middle Earth Shadow of
Mordor and uh now we're going to take
take a look at some of the indie games
on the show floor with Shawn mcginness
and Mary
Kish I was walking around looking at
just anything that caught my eye and
everyone knows Monaco it's like for the
people anyway so they were showing it
off but turns out right next to it they
were showing off lead over fire but it's
in the same style I love how they do
this he's known for kind of taking
licated game mechanics and reducing them
down to like one or two button types
simplifying the crap out of them that's
pretty much what Monaco is like a
complicated Heist game made simple and
frantic and fun that's exactly right
it's kind of like this real time
strategy RTS style uh like Starcraft but
he reduced it to two buttons it's the
same thing where you have to start
building your foundation with this one
your slaughtering pigs to get products
then you can start um raising units
units are ridiculous they're you start
out with like wraps you can move on to
flying
donkeys and you're attacking the other
person's base to ultimately defeat them
all right well I also saw an animal
themed game called bear zerkers go on
it's a competitive local action game
where four players play armadillos of
course and these armadillos are rolling
around this map and these maps are kind
of laid out in such a way where they
encourage like kind of like continuous
looping around through like common like
choke points and that type of thing the
twist here is that you're all trying to
run away from a murderous Anda bear
you're all rolling around and your basic
ability is as armadillos you can kind of
like dig this little trench in the
ground that creates this kind of like
dirt wall that actually blocks off these
other players so when two of you are
trying to run away from a bear and the
other player is a little bit farther
behind you can seal him off at a choke
point and he's stuck and the bear comes
and devours him and he loses a life so
the whole thing is just about like
finding like these movement patterns
throughout the map and just trying to
sabotage other players this is really a
show for the people it's about seeing
things you might not have ever seen
before weird experiences and I had a
hell of a weird experience seeing a game
unlike any other uh it was called sound
self Robin Arno is kind of known for
making these pretty Whimsical style
games that are supposed to make you look
internally and think about life deep
stuff it's hard to do that at that bear
with me here okay okay bear oh I get it
yeah bear with me here topical so I laid
down on a subwoofer on my back I put a
device around my neck that gauged the my
vocal cords and uh Oculus on my eye eyes
and then a headphones my voice was
changing the game Dynamics and telling
me to chant to kind of influence the
sounds and sights that were happening to
me uh all based on my tone and the
inflections of my voice I asked him what
kind of reactions he's been getting from
people and he said most of the time
people don't know how to react because
they're so like blown away by this weird
experience that they're really not sure
what to say he's actually had people
come out of it crying he's had people
coming out of it excited and or like
super zened out and it's it was a unlike
anything else that I've ever experienced
like very interesting visual colors with
a unique experience for me and I think
that's something cool that most people
probably don't ever get to experience
the past yeah I mean that's one thing
that I really like about the Indie Mega
Booth is that you can find those weird
off-kilter offbeat games like I found
one called the magic circle so it is a
video game um about making video games
which is already super meta um and so
this game is actually about like this
legendary vaporware product that's just
like exists in The Ether and has just
never been finished and you you get into
it and you're a player in this
world and you actually like hear
dialogue between two different
developers working on it and they're
constant constantly bickering with each
other suddenly out of nowhere this voice
appears who tells you you know what this
is a great opportunity you need to take
advantage of this situation you can
actually finish this game or just
sabotage it if you want to doesn't
matter it's up to you it's a world
that's ready to be exploited interesting
so that manifests itself in very
interesting ways like any object in the
game you can actually like freeze it and
then like jump into its AI profile and
actually like swap out its different
kind of like alliances and abilities and
things like that so like one thing I did
in the game was take these like little
dog creatures that start attacking you
instantly jump in turn them friendly
make them my pals and then maybe on one
or two of them I removed their ability
to walk took that kind of ground
transportation profile pocketed it went
to a mushroom gave it the ability to
walk and suddenly I have like a small
army of dogs and mushrooms to do my
bidding but that's just like a really
small part of it like you actually use
this stuff to solve really complex
environmental puzzles so it it all
builds up in really interesting ways and
I was talking to the guys and they said
that like it's still very possible for
players to break the game but that's
also kind of the fun for them is that
also possibly a way to win because you
can sabotage the game by breaking he
told me it's a game where you can either
finish it or you can cancel the game so
I feel like there are a different
Pathways you can take but once you
actually sit down and play it and it all
kind of starts to click you realize this
game is really cool and it's doing
something totally crazy I don't know if
it has any Mass Market appeal because
it's so meta and inside baseball but I
had a blast playing it that's awesome it
seems like that is a theme Here It packs
I've seen a lot of games that are in
there like infant stages they're not
ready yet I'm shocked that they're even
showing some of them because they're
like very early art stage but it's about
the experience and just enjoying the
game and you're right A lot of these
games might not ever be in stores but
it's it's about that true PS experience
of trying something new and getting
getting a really good story out of
it
I don't know lots to see at PX Prime of
course and we've got a new game just
announced your first look at it here
live on our stage show well I mean you
maybe have looked at it a little bit
over the weekend but joining me is are
Dan and Will from the Behemoth guys big
weekend for you huh oh yeah it's been
great you know we're unveiling game four
which I do want to say is a temporary
name a temporary it's a temporary name
but it's alien homedy Castle Crashers
battle block theater game four exactly
uh but you guys released this sort of
announcement trailer and if anyone any
of you have ever been to packs you know
the Behemoth you guys are always a big
Presence at packs people like walking
around with your plushies you guys are
on lanyards you got tons of place but
stations that are always full of people
playing your games so uh pretty special
for you guys to be showing off a game
for here at pack for it's been a lot of
fun and for anybody wondering what we're
calling it is a fastpaced turn-based
co-op adventure game I interrupted you
it's okay it's got a lot to it fastpaced
turnbas Co-op Adventure game mhm all
right well let's we're going to Dive
Right In and get a look at it but to
intro it's you folks we're going to take
a look at the intro sequence we're going
to let you hear the voiceover in all its
Glory done by by the way this man will
right over here yeah that's you will
yeah let's check it out don't hide me up
too much
man
I find myself wondering what the world
must have been like before the bear
crashed into our frail Planet
transforming all we once knew into a
colorful Kaleidoscope of delicious chaos
and I love it the world was more
hospitable no doubt more orderly more
sensibly sickening because it sounded
boring and I hate being bored I can't
imagine a world without the bear or the
storms yes the storms beautiful waves of
emerald blood cried down from the
heavens promising death in Lawless
disarray constantly upsetting the order
I get butterflies in my tummy just
thinking about
it yes yes speaking of
with tast the old stamper in
action all right so here we are starting
off yeah in the middle of one of the
storms that will mention St my friend
yeah this is Horatio the blueberry ber
farmer and his um he's about to
experience some of the chaos that all
the bear space bear blood is creating um
one thing I want to show off is the um
space bear blood raining down causing
all sorts of chaos I love it it's mixing
space and time as we know it and htio is
having to deal with some of that um so
one thing that's really big on the game
here is the movement system it's uh
mechanically very simple you can see as
you move the cursor around you can see
your potential path you hit a and then
you hold down Y and execute your turn
love them hexes um so a lot of it's
really streamlined we'll get to that in
a second this is our first hard counter
in the game mhm so heavy Shields are
really good at blocking arrows most
arrows not all they'll still get through
you got some not it won't block all the
arrows uh so are you is the player then
tapping a button here or is there it's
sort of uh to defensive status yeah he's
not doing he's not doing anything yeah
it's just
enemies to take their turn right so now
same thing movement he says let's go
here and Horatio automatically decides
well I got a sword I might as well use
it yeah right so we're trying to
streamline it's more of a game of
positioning than it is choosing an
ability and then a Target and all that
because that it's essentially like chess
if you want to think of it that way as
opposed to getting next to a guy and
then pausing the game with your
equipment menu and then having to go
through and I think I'll put this okay
let's get back to the fight now y you
might have seen right there Horatio he
went between two guys right there that
are bordering him Y and you don't know
which one he's going to hit because he
can now potentially choose between two
guys so if you want to choose your
target you want to get to their flank
and you can focus fire on units that way
with multiple guys you know the two
options oh my god oh yeah I was just
going to say oh sweet all those enemies
are gone but yeah it was looking up for
him for a second there but probably not
for long this uh as we could tell from
the opening intro not like a a happy
world not a wonderful place no it's a
horrible place to live it's a horrible
place to live well if you were to take
all time and space as we knew it and put
it in one spot I think there'd be a lot
of stuff that wasn't it'd be a little
chaotic it'd be a little messy and there
would be space Be Blood yeah so we're
getting a look at our world map here for
the first time and uh so you can look
around and then you can just move
wherever you need to go thankfully it's
very well marked in the beginning
Horatio is just trying to take cover
he's he's out in the bar rain that's a
terrible idea so he's just trying to get
somewhere and look it's his shelter we
all know what happened to that and we
got another cinematic right here she
looked hungry hero shared his
blueberries you got no you shared your
berries how generous of you her name was
pipistrella and though she looked more
than capable she requested Horatio's Aid
you see her castle was raided by grumpy
Warriors and she doesn't like that very
much go on my little hero perhaps this
could be become a mutually beneficial
relationship so there we meet pip
Estrella who's talking who's that guy
that's this guy right here I mean I know
it's you but like who are you in this
game the the narrator or is this one of
the Myster man you'll find that out
later yeah that's all right all right
that's not clear to us yet he really
loves the chaos though he's really into
this for some reason he definitely is um
so pipistrella she's got different stuff
than her ra she's got a heavy Mallet and
a light sword so that heavy Mallet is a
big deal here we can see it's going to
bash the heck out of helmets and helmets
are our defense in the game whereas
Horatio's sword not going to do so good
uh but there's some archers off to the
right there and so we're going to keep
htio closer to the archers so he draws
their fire and pipistrella is going to
smash the heck out of that helmet there
and you might see that she's making gold
while she does that too making gold what
are you going to do with gold when the
world has turned to horrible bare rain
chaos going to mean something
people still pay for stuff when the
world is undone I guess that sense
survive currency you know it's the
apocalyptic
capitalism yeah you know I I don't know
something things never Chang New Gear I
mean you know htio could use a hat as
much as that mustache is wonderful hel
yeah and that's actually something in a
little bit will show you you can
customize characters and things like
that so these guys aren't totally tied
in um we'll show you that a little bit
later all right I really do like Piper's
adorable little Shields yeah those guys
have little bucklers too a that's so
cute it doesn't do that much but you
know sometimes it does every little bit
helps I guess they're tiny bucklers yeah
I didn't even notice that her entire
Army is dead you can see them all dead
on the ground there that's cuz they use
swords it's just a bad idea against
helmets Unfortunately they didn't know
that Horatio's in a bit of a tight spot
if she hadn't hadn't hadn't run into her
so you're controlling both characters
here
right you can move both of your
characters before locking they'll take
the same turn they'll they'll move at
the same time that your turn will play
out yeah yeah they'll head out and do
their thing and the neat thing about
this game is there's counterattacks
there's criticals there's misses there's
Dodges there's all kinds of stuff that
you just can't be prepared for and you
got to just work with the chaos yeah
every match ends up different and you're
even talking about I mean even with the
positioning you know if you're next to
two enemies there's uncertainty about
which one you're going to tag
you know you might prefer to strike one
over the other but let's I guess htio is
going to do what htio going to do yeah
you never know like for instance here's
a space shuttle so space and time's all
messed up they're misusing a space
shuttle as their getaway vehicle cuz
it's just it was there it was there I
guess you know you got to make do with
what it was there and the keys were in
the ignition yeah yeah so we're going to
head up to the city here um cuz we still
have to take cover the castle is not in
a very good shape when you are taking
cover you want the cover to not be on
fire is like a general tactical rule
yeah right you definitely want work that
out unless you're immune to fire in
which case it's not so bad which case
you're all good uh what were those those
little zombies there's some zombies
there's some cupcakes there's robots
there's all kinds of stuff everything
from time and space is here so there's
some yeah you can see oh look at that
and then so we've made it to the city
and it's got a little prompt there it
says if you're lost press B let's try it
so we can show off our what we call our
breadcrumb system so if the world map's
huge and if you get lost you can leave
yourself a little trail of bread
crumbs that's poop breadcrumbs you know
bread breadcrumbs gets pooping on the
ground right now yeah but if you were
lost in a forest and you left
breadcrumbs on the ground do you think
they'd stay there very long you know
yeah that's true
lest like to eat breadcrumbs less like
to eat poop I would imagine yeah I mean
there's probably something that like you
poop in this world right yeah all space
and time that could be true but we don't
we haven't seen it yet so Horatio and
pipistrella they need to make some gold
so they've gone to the arena but they
need a third fighter and conveniently
this half Cyclops was outside and he
says do you want to join Souls let's say
no cuz that's weird that's intense and
he's well so oh he he's trying to please
us trying to intense prer more beard
than Mohawk guess okay so let's join
Souls with the half Cyclops who I mean
nothing could go wrong right what I mean
so let's get in there and just get some
Golds this place is was bumping by the
way the city you know even though
stuff's going down the city's still got
a good spirit people still like their
blood sport oh yeah you know they they
don't know any different they don't
leave the walls um so here we see y's in
a bad Spoto says oh maybe I should be up
there to soak up that fire
and we can see ysep is able to throw his
axes and has a chance to stun he can get
in there in melee it's just not as good
of an idea for him so what we're going
to do is put Horatio in front of ysep
and have ysep throw axes from the back
line and hopefully stun that guy with
the ues cuz cuz he's a jerk cuz Uzi
there is perfect who brings Uzi to a
medieval battle fight so we were able to
focus fire a unit just because he he
made a misstep so there's there are ways
to you know all go for one guy there mhm
and and it's all about picking at your
targets and seeing who's weak we can see
pipistrella she still hates helmets so
she's going to go after the guy with the
helmet oh so she has sort of a if she G
if she's given the choice between two
strikable enemies will she go for helmet
generally
or Aaron who's driving in the back just
decided he's going to go for what's
strategically sound you can totally make
the wrong decisions oh yeah we we love
we love to let you guys make all the
wrong decisions we allow you to do that
that's very kind of you that's part of
the part of the
process um but you so you do have to
choose targets you know for the melee
units you choose the Target by walking
next to it and for the rang unit you get
to pick a Target specifically yeah so
there's there's a whole system where as
you're moving that a around yeah the
target reticles will light up on who's a
potential Target so you can move ysep
around and see can we do that for a
second Aaron can show yeah yeah so see
how same thing for ysep if he's in range
you'll see oh he can strike that
guy uh now I'm seeing a lot of numbers
pop up as the arrows are coming in and
these heroes are taking like a champ but
I'm but I'm not seeing any health bars
on screen or anything like that you you
will okay all right you that's we're
just still early days here I can I'll
actually I can go into that right now
actually so um ysf is a is part of
Cyclops lore and cyclopses can see the
future cuz they traded one of their eyes
to the gods but all they could see is
when they were going to die ysph um just
knows how dead he is and you join Souls
with him and you just made that official
by killing each like killing things in
the arena so now you can see it too in
the next fight so that's that's why you
can see that sounds like you should try
to get more soulmates we just made a
bunch of uh gear from our fight and now
after we choose who's going to be our
hero and all of them are an okay choice
they just hit harder and they have more
Health you can pick anybody you want um
the emperor gives us a house because we
fought so awesomely oh wow and in the
house this is where the game starts to
really open up this is where you can see
a lot of the potential along the bottom
you can see there's four more slots down
there we only have three guys right now
uhhuh and you can see Aron Aaron's
customizing uh his guys you can say you
know what I want pipistrella to be
something else you can do that or you
can just be like you know what I want
the banana uh mallet instead of the
regular Mallet of course you guys would
have weird Weaponry I love it the large
naner yeah so you can just I mean you
can pretty much do um whatever you want
with the gear that you find so we just
gave you kind of the Baseline of how it
works and then you're allowed to do any
kind of strategy you want and there's
other creatures in the game like you saw
some of the cupcakes and the zombies you
can put those on your team if you get
some oh really you can you can mix and
match around the yeah yeah you can mix
and match all you want so the Emperor
says oh you know um I gave you a house
you ow me you got to take care of these
guys out by the beach indentured and so
it's our first Quest so the quest system
it shows caran yeah yeah totally you can
fill the wagon with stuff and all that
but we'll get into that a little bit
later on oh there's the bear yeah there
he is with his star nipples and you see
you know the arrow will tell you where
to go on your quest and uh you can just
you can fight that guy that's actually
what a full Cyclops looks like but he's
got a helmet on you can't see his eye uh
right that's a big Cyclops uh quick
question this is very important
logistically uhhuh the breadcrumbs that
you leave when you are in a caravan is
it the poops of the beasts pulling the
Caravan or the poops of the people
inside the car yeah so the beasts in the
Caravan can infinitely poop okay yeah
excellent if people are pooping in the
Caravan the beasts are leaving it on the
ground they're supplement yeah they're
keeping it inside so you can see down
there there's the HUD you can see the
health how far they move and then
there's the purple bar the purple bar
far as experience so as every time you
are to hit someone on a turn you gain
some experience and if you get that last
hit of that guy you get a big bonus um
leveling up in this game will heal you
it's the only way to heal in a fight
aside from a unit that heals right other
units but the the Priestess cupcake the
cupcake the cupcake heals other units
for instance but these guys have to rely
on their own experience just when they
level up they're going to fully heal so
you can have a guy soak up up a bunch of
damage and then have him level up like
it meant nothing and it's all good and
he's stronger so and so it see I mean
the way you're talking about it it seems
like it's not just going to be something
that comes along as a nice bonus during
combat and you're like oh great I'm glad
that happened but something you would
actively
strategize have your weak player land
that last hit you could pull an entire
match back and have one guy left and
take out a whole team of people if you
level up at that right moment you're
chaining the levels together it gets it
gets really interesting there's some
very interesting mechanics in in just
how fundamentally different this is
where if you have low-l characters you
have an advantage in certain ways that
they're going to be able to heal during
the fight whereas a super highlevel guy
is not going to have as much of a chance
to level well not nearly as much
actually and uh he'll be you know
beefier and all that but if you if you
want to rely on that kind of thing you
need lower level guys so you got to keep
getting new guys and stuff yeah there's
no way to the only way to like restrict
your own leveling would be to not get
the maybe not get get the killing blow
as often right uh so maybe it behooves
you to do that yeah so I mean however
you want to do or you can power level
someone on your team and let them keep
getting the last hit however you want to
like shape it is it's all up to you I
mean you could bring all mallets you
could bring all those um there's a lot
of hard counters in the game so that
might be really bad if you do that but
you're welcome to try out anything and
like you said before you're welcome to
make bad decisions you can do it yeah
and you can learn you know if you lose a
character it's okay because they they'll
come back in normal difficulty yeah you
run back to the we do plan on having an
insane difficulty but we haven't quite
worked out what that is lots of people
are suggesting Perma death I don't know
sure that could be scary that could be
really scary but per death is supposed
to be scary yeah it's scary it's death
yeah um so we're almost we've almost got
these guys I'm feeling pretty good about
that um so I do want to mention to you
that there is Co-op
so the way Co-op would work is you would
have your set of guys and I have my set
of guys okay and we would um take all
our moves and then we would both say I'm
ready you're ready and then they all of
blue would move out and then all red
would go and so it's very similar to the
same kind of pace that we're doing here
now would it scale up uh the the
encounters like is is the
co-op you could be playing this map
Co-op or you could be playing it solo
it's just sort of seamless with the the
game so the game will will balance based
on how many guys you have it doesn't
necessarily mean more guys although
normally it does uh um they might be a
little more powerful just because
otherwise there's no challenge yeah so
yeah the game does Scale based on you
know how many people you have and and
and all that and of course your progress
in you know we play a little bit Co-op
then I'm going to go play a little bit
solo my progress is continuous across
the whole thing yes you keep your same
guys when you cross into multiplayer or
not um there's advantages in in Co-op
you know you uh you have more guys that
can cover you and and you can bring
stuff that you've never been able to
bring alone because if you want to bring
all cupcakes that's not going to work if
you're alone right but I can support
your team or I can have like I'm going
to have a couple of these and a couple
of that and and we could bring way more
Giants if we're both together than if we
were alone and things like that I see
and here's our fourth um companion she
has no idea what's going on she didn't
know that while she was trying to find
the new world that space and time got
screwed up she was out in the ocean so
she's like oh cool I'm I've made it I
claim the land do you want to be my
guides and you agree because well you
know why not I guess I guess so so she's
super you got a boat that seems cool and
this is unfortunately where our our demo
ends we do have a a a video that sort of
encapsulates it pretty short uh so is
that going to tack on the end here I'd
love to tack that on the end let let's
do that let's watch that right here here
thank you for playing now go away no way
stay it's only fair to prepare you for
what to C you'll find yourself in the
city maybe with a friend maybe inside
your precious little house customizing
your team's looks and strategies then
it's off you pop to the market to
purchase I don't know dainty dresses for
all your warriors so they look pretty as
little peaches as they prance from Epic
Quest to Epic Quest laughing in eating G
meeting new Heroes getting stronger
maybe getting a little too arrogance cuz
it's all in vain and at the end of the
day you're all my precious little
puppets and we're going to have some fun
see you
so all right uh will doing this kind of
voice over getting a little maniacal
with it do you ever have you ever come
out of a session and your co-workers are
looking at you a little differently like
you you went to a dark place there buddy
no it's expected by this point they know
you well enough we know him you know
we've been working him for years and
it's great because you know I'll just
give him a bullet point hey we need to
convey this and then he just writes it
all does it all I never know what I'm
going to get very cool all right Dan
will thank you guys so much for coming
off getting our awesome first look at
game four from the Behemoth Xbox One and
steam in case you missed it Xbox One and
steam you guys have a general timeline
no release date however we have held on
to this game longer than we usually hang
on to our games or true so usually you
know Castle Crush we showed it like 4
months in this has been in velopment
about twice or maybe a little bit longer
than that so you don't have to wait as
long I think because we waited longer to
show it excellent well I'm sure a lot of
people looking forward to getting their
hands on it thank you guys so much much
appreciated enjoy the rest of your packs
we are going to be coming back to the
stage show doing a little time bending
of time and space of our own for demo of
Mortal Kombat in just a few minutes but
first Peter Brown is going to talk to us
about some indie
games video games 2014 we're here at
pack
what's up Chris
Waters M that Behemoth game looks so
good it the Behemoth game looks so good
I just had to get a little bit Shake It
Off Shake It Off Peter Brown you spend
some time in a hotel room with the
creator of Final Fantasy tell me about
it oh sorry it's pretty distracted for a
second uh Shake It Off oh man so many
things uh yeah no I met up with her noas
sakaguchi the man who created Final
Fantasy over 20 years ago he has a
company called Mist Walker he left
square that happened he was making a lot
of console games now he's working in the
mobile space he's got a free-to-play
mobile tactical puzzle RPG coming out
watch y explain to me why I want to know
about a free-to-play tactical RPG on a
mobile device Peter brand do it okay
well let's talk about the game first
rather than the free-to-play model so it
is a grid based game where you have a
bunch of units on the battlefield there
are units you're competing against and
it's all about aligning things and
sandwiching enemies in between your own
characters if you have characters
Elsewhere on the map that are aligned it
sort of like multiplies the damage you
guys team up you do really well there's
a lot of depth and strategy to explore
there and it's pretty difficult but it
is free to play and that's not
necessarily a bad thing in principle but
the problem is this is one of those
games where you can only play for a
certain amount of time and then you've
exhausted a meter and you have to wait
for it to recharge playing the game
yesterday I actually really liked it a
lot and I could see myself wanting to
play it for a long time so it's really
disappointing and they have no option
for a full price release would you
prefer to spend like $30 not you just be
able to play it is it that much of a dis
disparity do you think yeah I would
totally like to do that I mean honestly
like it's it's one of those things where
I just want to pay for the game and have
the game and at that point I'm not
really worried about getting my money
back I've already got it but if I'm
thinking about spending real world money
to play a game that's sort of fantasy
and not real I mean that the
intersection of those two things bugs me
anyway you know so is it is it like kind
of Final Fantasy Tactics is what I'm
seeing in my head no that's like a grid
based game it's similar kind of similar
to what we saw there not a little bit
different but uh no this this is more of
it's similar to like chess where
different pieces that you have affect a
single piece of the enemies on the
battlefield um but you know what's
really good is they have noo uatu the
composer who's been with Final Fantasy
forever he's done about 20 tracks for it
um and they're doing sort of an
interesting thing with it it they're
doing a download starter so essentially
the more people download the game the
more things they're going to do in terms
of adding new content and one of those
things is if it gets to 2 million
downloads they're going to create a
full-fledged MMO RPG based on this world
yeah I know it's very insane and you
knobby knobby boy but with actually
making games instead of planet right and
you don't you need to spend any money
you just download it and you're
basically contributing towards this
effort it's almost just voting with a
little bit of your own effort or energy
rather than your dollar fair enough yeah
crazy weird it is weird it is weird but
it looks fun and uh I mean he describes
it as another branch on the gaming trees
trying to explore whatever it's a
business decision but uh you know i'
curious to see what he could do with the
world cuz it's a mix of fantasy it's a
mix of sci-fi there were 160 characters
in the game that all have their own
backstory uh all these different nations
with their own languages so it's got a
lot of potential I just want to see it
kind of breach that business decision
that kind of spr it along you know
when's it coming out uh he's not saying
just yet they're not positive so yeah
all right 2015 like everything else here
at PX H first of all uh or lastly Before
I Let You Go you beautiful man cuz I
know you got a lot of work to do tell me
about your panel last night it was on at
the same time as a giant bomb but
apparently you still like filled out a
massive chunk of this big ass room we
filled out a decent chunk uh Chris ker
from W has been running the Retro Game
Road Show for a few years it's like the
Antiques Road show that maybe you've
seen on TV people bring in their items
it gets appraised by experts apparently
I'm one of those experts uh and uh yeah
so people brought in some of their rare
video gaming items last night and we
appraised them live in front of a studio
audience and it was great uh one of them
was a music box that came out during
Final Fantasy 7 uh it is incredibly high
quality the mechanics are like like
perfect the wood is made to resonate
with music and it played uh SS's theme
song from Final Fantasy 7 you know that
the song that sort of reminds everyone
like spoiler she dies right uh too soon
man yeah boo too soon oh
man I think it's only gam spotters that
are booing right it's sea mcginness yeah
um but you know that when no when uh her
noas saki Gucci was making that game his
mother passed away and it's a very you
feel bad now don't you Sean somebody
real died you
mother so a somber event a somber song
from the game and he had signed the
music box across the top which we kind
of thought maybe that that would tarnish
the value of it but if you kind of put
it into a historical perspective it
actually kind of adds something special
to it in a way so that was pretty
interesting the moment we turn he
cranked it up and turned it on the whole
audience just everyone's kind of shut
down it was really sad was that the
rarest thing you saw yeah I mean that
alone is worth $3,000 wow yeah so uh
it's really rare it's really high
quality and uh it was really neat cool
crazy all right what you doing for the
rest of your packs we're almost done and
dusted here I'm paying attention to kg
aun panel coming up the Mega Man Creator
who's talking about his newest game
Monday number nine and there's supposed
suppos to be maybe a secret announcement
we'll find out pack Secrets right here
on gamespot.com uh but what we're going
to do a little time travel here I'm
going to shoot it to myself talking to a
dude while I'm wearing a different shirt
I bear Mortal Kombat
X video
games hello welcome back to games spots
continuing coverage of Penny Arcade Expo
2014 my name is Dan D and I'm delighted
to be joined by Mr Adam arbano pleasure
NE r Studios that's me you guys are
making a new Mor Kombat game that's what
I hear I yeah it's h you guys have had a
sort of a Renaissance in MK of the past
like five or six years yep uh what's the
new challenge when Mortal Kombat X uh
the goal is so with nine we rebooted the
franchise back to the basics uh 2D
functionality really good looking
graphics and balance with x the
challenge is how do we take that and
advance that storyline all those
features and make it something that is
the next true Mortal Kombat game after
the reboot you guys are leaning into
that storyline pretty pretty hard came
back in MK versus DC obviously he's a
big part of MK9 as well now we've got
Johnny Cage having babies what the
goddamn hell is happening uh so X being
sort of a metaphor for uh obviously MKX
the 10th version of the of the franchise
but also the next generation of consoles
okay and the next generation of
characters sure uh so you're going to
see a lot of growth through story takes
place between 5 and 25 years after the
events of MK9 so you get to see things
like Johnny Cage's uh daughter Cassie
yeah can you fight her as Johnny Cage uh
yeah you could great yeah video games we
got some uh we got some beeroll of the
game here I I played a bit of it at uh
Gamescom you guys unveiled a bunch of
new characters as well um talk a little
bit the the sort of the new characters
are coming to the franchise cuz
obviously you know Subzero scorpion
those Staples we've already seen a lot
of yep so uh some of the sort of new
characters to the franchise overall uh
we have Calon sort of an Aztec based
fighter a lot of powers based upon light
and darkness and sort of tradition
values uh we have Farah and T my sort of
favorite because you get this giant sort
of guy in T and then the little person
on his back it's terrifying I that that
that fatality is awful with the with the
splitting down the middle it's pretty
nicy yeah the nextg stuff lets us do
some pretty cool stuff with hard uh
fatalities uh and then you're looking at
uh we have d'vorah that we've shown
who's sort of this insect based
character uh a lot of powers based upon
Little Creatures she uses uh so one of
the cool things is we designed them to
kind of fit the MK l cuz we wanted
people to sort of immediately recognize
these as characters that they feel
they've known forever I feel like the MK
is pretty broad though yeah well you got
you got ninjas with ice and then dudes
with with freaking is does Bara have a
baby uh can't confirm that yet okay
we're looking at some footage here we
got some uh well one very familiar
character in Raiden uh and actually no
on Kano as well very from to so this is
the one of our newer jungle levels uh
and we're seeing example of Raiden sort
of various Powers cuz one of the one of
the things we've done with this game one
of the big gameplay features is variance
yeah so you've like split is that every
character's got three different sets of
of move sets so their their move set
like at its core is still uh shared
across characters cuz we don't want you
have to learn three different raes but
they each have these fundamental powers
that are unique to each branch each
variation uh and it changes the way you
play so you're going to have uh more
defensive along one particular variant
versus something more offensive your
strategy is going to change you're going
to have different unique specials and
abili
uh it's really cool and really fun to
balance was that ever a worry
considering Mortal Kombat has always
been the sort of more accessible of the
fighting games that like you're going to
over complicate things for people yes
we're we're very cognizant of that so we
wanted to make sure that this isn't
something you could change during
gameplay and that sort of the core
mechanic you can still you know whatever
variant you choose is there so the
variants are sort of more something that
affects strategy and gives you
additional moves but if you just want to
sort of butt mash and just have a good
time it's going to be the same across
all the variant uh as well speaking
about the sort of differences between MK
and and a bunch of other fighting games
you guys have kind of always sat on the
periphery of the fighting game community
in terms of uh like um Esports or in
terms of like competitive stuff is that
always a has that been a concern maybe
this time around that you guys want to
get get in on that is that maybe what
the variants are kind of well actually
was our first foray into sort of the
technical fighter was the Evo um it was
an EVO game and it was something that we
were really focused on you know getting
into that sort of serious market and The
credibility so with MKX we're taking
everything we learned and making sure
that everything available for sort of
that tournament level player is there
cuz that's something we want you know
it's the uh easy to learn lifetime to
master concept as well as as just sick
ass oh God what's he that's great yeah
okay so that obviously is a fatality um
nextg fatality where we can do all the
things we've always wanted letting the
people that come up with them uh go a
little crazy the L generation of
consoles has finally allowed Ed Boon's
nasty death fantasies to become real all
of well the teams fantasies become real
it's not just Ed in a room with a piece
of paper just writing ourano to burst
through Raiden's head I want that little
girl to slice straight down lady's backs
with her with her knife um he's
certainly very much kind of the
Visionary of each fatality uh but yeah
it's not him alone in a in a room I
think he appreciates the help now this
is a fighting game coming out and if uh
working in this side of video games
industry is anything you guys are going
to be trickling out details and
specifics over the next coming weeks and
months I'm yeah so I I'm going to guess
if I well I ask you what characters are
coming and probably you guys have a plan
to like start telling people real slow
right yeah we sort of that's the kind of
thing we think about uh is how to keep
people you know excited and interested
in some of the crazy choices we made on
roster
Babalities could be anything friendships
could be anything godamn it all right
that's fair enough H another thing you
when I was playing in Gamescom as well
another thing you guys have done as uh
kind of lean into that environmental um
killing or environmental inter
interactions yeah yeah cuz there was
there was a bit of that in in nine and
DC there was sort of the the transition
stuff there was a bit in nine uh they
seem to be a lot more of them or may
maybe easier to trigger at MKX so it's
uh it's something we explored with
Injustice it was a chance to go a little
crazy with a new franchise and try
things that you know wouldn't
necessarily fit in MK and then we took
the stuff that really worked out well
and we kind of adjusted it to fit that K
universe so you're going to see stuff
all along the fight line that you can
just play with and it's really easy to
use just you know R1 and you suddenly go
and throw a tree or uh jump off of an
object and there's traps there's
offensive there's defensive stuff and
it's super sort of casually accessible
but you can do things like combo into
them uh and and use them as part of your
attacks if you're more of an advanced
player yeah I remember seeing one in the
jungle stage where it was it was a Vine
hanging down and it actually enabled you
to sort of leap across which is kind of
a a new yeah it's like almost like
moving around the the map is Chang the
idea is to give you sort of take away
some of the advantages that you would
typically have like if you're in a
corner there's a lot of interactable
that let you escape that corner yeah so
you're not getting pummeled all the time
uh so we really enjoyed that chance to
kind of scatter those objects like that
tree stump which just glowed all across
the sort of fight line uh yeah and here
we are looking at two uh fan favorites
Scorpion and Subzero um how do you take
a guy like scorpion specifically who I
guess people are used to an entire move
set off
andf himit it up like I know like
Subzero can throw his ice clone in one
of
the what's yeah do you think that might
like fans will be a bit maybe irked that
they can't do like teleportation moves
as well as flame moves or so we've been
really careful to make sure that the
core you know the core character even
before you picked your variant has all
the stuff that people sort of relate to
the character the core stuff you would
know from you know MK1 in the arcade
that classic feel so you're still going
to it's you're going to have your
traditional sort of Scorpion throw
Spears and and his teleport but it's the
addition of new moves you get uh in the
variant that way we're not sort of
breaking that traditional character cuz
we're obviously very sort of aware of of
what these characters are and how
important they are to keep you know
perfectly classic uh you guys had this
um playable for price and stuff at
Gamescom is there is it playable on the
show floor at all no sadly it's still
holding it back still holding it back uh
a lot of the reason is there's stuff
that we're super excited about that
we're just not quite ready to show um so
once we get that together uh we'll be
ready to go soon and very soon I like it
h yeah what's that like I guess getting
a game like MKS into people's hands like
you've been involved in the franchise
for for a while now yep since DC how
important is it like that sort of aspect
of it of like actually watching people
play oh uh it's almost painful until you
get to that point just cuz we're so
excited to get people's hands on it and
especially as we sort of Hit the balance
stage and sort of tune and learn about
it um we bring in people uh so we have a
group of you know either uh people we
just invite or tournament Players that
we get to have get that early look and
help us and then once we hit the show
floor that's when the fun magic happens
and you'll see us just standing there
watching for hours cuz it's you know you
learn a ton and it's really cool to see
how people focus on stuff we didn't
necess think they would yeah H Raiden
here fighting a new character yeah so
that's uh that's Cal con so that's the
Aztec based character that is KH in the
surname does that mean that he or she is
some sort of I don't know important top
tier character they're all important in
terms of the the the the tower in terms
of the is there any shaan uh no there's
uh he's it's just kodal con uh sort of
more as that South American Aztec
reference more than any specific
character got I thought it was like a
son or a cousin or a nephew yeah most
people do so uh no he's all new and
again he's designed so that he feels
like somebody who would have been around
forever that's sort of brutal look there
you're seeing sort of some of what
brutal means particularly for this
character throw a freaking barrel full
of lemons on him yep uh so that's some
of the interactions uh and then here
you're seeing the variations on the
characters this a good example this
one's a crazy one this is like you can
almost make sort of like I don't know
barriers out of multiple like lightning
balls I love that one so it's it's very
much focused around defense and traps
and hiding so you're seeing him like
bring up these Ice uh sorry these uh
electric little balls that become
defensive units around you and where you
place them and how you use them uh
becomes sort of the core of that
character so yeah him using the power of
the Sun in that case uh yeah oh yeah
that'll do it kick to the jaw is that
massive tiger in the background
interactive it is actually uh you can
jump off his head um and maybe at some
point he gets angry okay fair enough so
there's Cal kex right oh God that's the
that's the worst like how is he able to
fight after that it's ridiculous uh
largely because if he I'm not giving out
World combat's realism yeah well it
wouldn't be much fun if first hit they'd
be dead so uh here we're going to see
another one
oh god oh that is just the worst
yep great love it raen wins so U
fatalities obviously always being a big
focus of MK and a lot of fun to make so
a lot of new tech went into making sure
that you know Ed and the team can do
whatever they want excellent H and when
will players be able to do whatever they
want it's coming out at a bunch of
platforms uh uh when I bet we're going
to be able to play Mor Kombat X uh sort
of the window of 2015 okay so we're
going to be you're going to be teasing
out that those details over the next
couple of weeks that's one of the fun
things that people get to learn very
hopefully very soon okay put Baraka in
it okay if you still taking suggestions
perfect Baraka has a kid
with reptile all right okay done
Babalities yep animalities no no maybe
friendships yep okay okay I will email
Ed right after this uh so I guess that's
in the game awesome thank you studos
thank you very much for coming on our St
show and yeah enjoy the rest of the
packs Co thank you so
much and with that our last live demo of
the PX Prime live show live is dead uh
we're going to wrap things up here at
sector G while Danny tries to double
double open my mom told me my mom told
me not to B bite my fingernails do it
God just Daniel D want get yours I could
use one of these packs blue ribbons
right now I'm drinking healthy water
nice work good hydration and fun
cheers all right Pax is a our live show
from Pax is a rapid Pax is still going
on all afternoon all day tomorrow uh but
you guys what have you what's what's
been your thing so far you've been all
you've been out and about been doing
hosting panel stuff you guys have all
been around a lot yeah we it started off
the two of us had panels the first day
which was kind of uh I thought that was
the best it was good to get them out of
the way because I think we were both
like pretty nervous or anticipating them
a little bit couldn't have planned it
better I'm so glad and it was really
good to start it start it with a bang
like have a really awesome uh ladies and
gaming panel and then went right over to
lose horribly and both you guys that
horribly we did we were not last you
were so good at Star wall I not last
whated the was not set up in a in a in a
legitimate way which would you know cuz
you guys actually did all right in star
wall and like yeah I don't know like so
are we cutting together a video of that
we are uh we had a disaster this morning
where we think the memory card corrupted
so Andy is currently in the back uh
trying to uh recover it so those are
those background video Terrors that no
one realizes happen and it always
happens with the one you really really
didn't want it to happen so the most
important sorry for the delay cuz we
weren't in a in a streaming room I think
the stream of uh women surviving and
thriving games media is up it's up it's
up and and ready for view way more
organized than me way more on point uh
all right so send folks off tell tell me
one thing they should check out or one
thing with the Highlight for you guys at
packs uh as a way of closing the show
out here absolutely uh I'm going to have
to say that even though the panels were
fantastic and I was happy to be a part
of them the Highlight was clearly
playing evolve
and kicking Chris's butt if I could just
get a closeup no um I'm Kraken Chris is
the medic he's running away right now
all my friends are dead and I eat him
right there there's a giant crocodile
that's the winning screen when I
murdered Chris yeah that was must it
must have felt really good to beat a
tiny medic with a [__] huge monster
man I ate all your comrades did you
literally eat them cuz when I beat you
and your friends I killed you and then I
ate the corpse and looked you in the eye
while I did you're how can you look me
in the eye when you're eating my eyes
I'm eating other people's corpses that
the eyeballs they're eating I don't know
evolve a lot of fun so much fun definit
the best for in the mega booth in the
mega booth in the mega booth and also
the sixth floor area which is like the
Overflow for the Mega Booth uh there is
some like it's it's it's wonderful it's
going to sound like such a like a a high
in Mighty I work in the gam press thing
but we just came back from game C so
like 80% of the stuff that's here at
this show is stuff that we literally
just spent an age looking at and E3
wasn't that far either that stuff is
there it's there and like for people who
are like coming to the show who don't
get the opportunity to go to Cologne or
go to La for for uh Gamescom like most
of that stuff is known quantities it's
trailers and previews you've seen on gam
site so like it's cool to like get hands
on with like evolve maybe the game that
you kind of need to play but the mega
Booth is like it's it's you're wandering
around and you don't know what you're
going to run into you might see some
games like you had Galaxy on the flooor
I saw that at Pax like that's there
again that's cool like Cannonball was
there I played like 50 hours of that but
then you're like yeah like M Plus+ was
there but then you run into stuff you
never even heard of before Sean was
showing bear zerker earlier really Co
did he talk about how he like really
like there was a little child he was
playing with and he did not like scale
his ability at all there like he
massacred a tiny this 8-year-old playing
the game and he just swamped
him no he didn't mention that left it
out weird the mega boot's great and like
everyone's just hanging around and like
yeah like bumping into Teresa again
we're going to H get those guys back on
the lobby in the next couple of weeks
like pumping into Alexander Bruce who
made anti chamber and talking about
games and it's great it's like cuz so
much of video games is the same stuff
repeated over and over again but in
there in there you've got yeah then
you've got stupid dumb nonsense like and
there's this that's got to be a
highlight yeah Far Cry 4 they're trying
to can you and I do this later in in do
you want to do that you want to do that
later I that might be fun I feel like we
should get I don't know if I want get
into the suit though that people have
been being hella sweaty in for the past
three days yeah that's that's a good
point actually that's straight up
elephants op if you want more uh packs
show floor greatness Danny I think
there's like a half hour tour of you
cruising around we shot that thing and
was like we'll use it for the show and
then and I was talking to Andy and we
break it up into like three sections or
something then I wander back in here
he's like I put it up I'm like what do
you mean it's all up it's like 32
minutes it's there so you want the
extended tour Danny's got you covered uh
the Highlight for me aside from you know
guests on this show Behemoth game 4
looks really cool uh was hosting the Civ
beyond Earth panel at on Saturday and
you know Danny you had the demo you
talked with those guys about beyond
Earth that game is really cool I'm
really excited for it I got to play it a
little bit but if you folks want to see
more about it there's an extended demo
and a lot of developer talk during that
panel which is posting Tuesday night on
Gamespot awesome so you can come back
and check it out then there's a little
Glimpse beyond Earth I would I could
just play that for like the rest of the
week I'm looking forward to watching on
P on the site because I don't have that
much exposure to this series but when I
was talking to the guys on the stage
yesterday like some of the stuff it's so
outside of what regular Civilization
games are doing like what you were
saying to me two days ago where history
is a known quantity like so much of
stuff that can happen in this like way
more so nentori is just like crazy
hypothetical future nonsense and they're
pulling from all kinds of sci-fi and
making references but also making stuff
up themselves uh and isn't making stuff
up what video games are all about that's
what video games are it's stuff that
made up all right uh everybody here at
sector G thank you so much for coming
and checking out our live
show you guys are awesome it's been a
pleasure to uh to host y'all here uh
there'll be more food out later I think
there some chicken tenders coming I'm
going to go eat them cheers thank you
all for watching online we've got a ton
more packs coverage just check out the
site to enjoy all that we're off to do
some more and then we'll be back uh on
Tuesday the live Lobby you'll have some
packs distilled and some more good stuff
coming for you for from Gamespot I'm
Chris waters for Dan O Mary Kish all the
Gamespot production team thank you so
much for watching our packs coverage
it's been a blast see you later video
game